what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so with superior spider-man we're
gonna cheat a little bit the reason why
I say that is because of the fact that
like the first three really though the
first story arcs technically three
issues but we're gonna cover the first
five
now the reason being because of the fact
it'll allow us a little bit of leeway
later on down the line when it comes
like one shots and so on and so forth
something else that I also want to
specify here is that it's well known by
now at least by most comic readers that
the spite of our storyline takes place
during superior spider-man so I'm trying
to figure out how I'm going to do this
so I'm gonna simply stop superior
spider-man most to get to that point and
then cover all the stuff we need going
into spider-verse or if I'm just gonna
cover superior spider-man and then wrap
back around and go into spider-verse the
only problem with that is that if we
were to cover all of superior spider-man
and then cover spider-verse towards the
end of the superior spider-man event
Doctor Octopus references spider-verse
so he'd literally be referencing an
event that we haven't covered yet or at
least I don't think we've covered very
well I didn't before about it really
like the way those videos were done
before so I'll get that figured out and
we've got a little while we've got you
know 20 some-odd issues before we have
to worry about that you know but I think
that uh you know with with regards to
this little tidbit right here what Dan
Slott does is actually makes you
superior spider-man wildly interesting
and if I'm gonna be dangerous I would
say that I think superior spider-man I
think Doctor Octopus is a better
spider-man than Peter Parker ah the
reason why is just because really is
ingenuity you know how he just kind of
revamps the spider suit and little
things that he does on the side I kind
of make his life a little bit easier
stuff that just spider-man just never
did and what this does is it actually
kind of allows Dan Slott to tinker
around with the spider-man mythos it's
almost like taking Peter Parker and
throwing him into some you know pocket
universe and then just experimenting
with stories using Doctor Octopus allows
Dan Slott to introduce ideas to the
spider-man mythos and then if people
like it he'll just keep it going forward
whence Peter Parker returns and so
because of this one of the things that
was established and amazing spider-man
number 700 really uh a landmark issue in
and of itself it was a beautifully
written story it established the idea
that a set of us as the reader expecting
Doctor Octopus to become spider-man and
just be a bad guy instead he becomes a
good guy but the way that he does it is
a little questionable that's one of the
reasons why I like it with regards to
this it's basically a reformed version
of the sinister six miss composed of a
handful of individuals you know like
overdrive and you know
shocker and so on and so forth the
living brain different things like that
but it's kind of funny because we could
kind of look at this and say that it's
like a poor man sinister six I guess is
nowhere near as great as you know that
the sinister six that we're used to as
it's led by Doctor Octopus and even you
know dr. octo is the spider-man and
we're just gonna call him spider-man
just for the sake of this but even
spider-man comments on that and you know
it's you could almost imagine him saying
you know back in my day the sinister six
was actually a deadly group you guys are
just goofballs you guys are nonsensical
but the funny thing is that in the
middle of fighting them he actually
bails off because for his first major
fight as spider-man he's going against a
group of six people all of whom have
some pretty interesting and unique
powers that we don't range anywhere from
you know throwing razors try boomerangs
all the way up to you know the ability
to administer massive amounts of
electricity and in terms of a shock and
so because of this what is up happening
here is spider-man actually kind of
dodges for a little bit Bob's and weaves
and they all basically make their escape
but in the process he actually damages
overdrive up with this you know some
little claws or something that he
attached to his fingers now on the
surface it seems like something totally
irrelevant and Dan Slott treats it that
way in fact what we end up doing is we
actually just kind of switch over to
Horizon labs and the reason why is
because the living brain was basically
defeated by you know by spider-man by
superior spider-man and then turn around
and take him back to Horizon lab so the
reason why this matters is because of
the fact that for those of you guys who
have been reading all-new all-different
amazing spider-man you'll notice Doctor
Octopus in the body of the living brain
now the living brain goes back quite
some time in the spider-man mythos but
he was always a small-time thing it was
a robot that was created eventually went
awry and that was it I mean that's
really all there is to the whole history
of the living brain this is probably the
most significant role that its character
has ever played in the history of the
spider-man mythos but with regards to
superior spider-man taking a living
brain this is Dan Slott setting the
stage for the return of Doctor Octopus
in the body of the living brain with
all-new all-different amazing spider-man
now I wouldn't go as far as to say Dan
Slott had this all planned out ahead of
time but I would say that it was more of
like a fail-safe that if you know his
stories took him in the direction where
the bodies were switched back and Doc
Ock lost his own body or something like
that he could come back in the form of
the living brain you know basically put
his mind inside the robot but the fact
remains here that's switching back over
to a superior spider-man and following
him further what Dan Slott does is he
takes all of this in phases that's
really what
it's just step by step now initially and
one of the things that we had noticed
superior spider-man have been paying
special attention to Mary Jane Watson as
anybody would if she were actually real
and because of this Dan Slott was kind
of toying with the idea
maybe spider-man and Mary Jane Watson
will end up getting back together now in
truth if you're a a Peter Parker Mary
Jane Watson fan superior spider-man and
Mary Jane Watson is just not the same
it's it's not equal they're not on par
it's like kissing your husband's twin as
opposed to your actual husband or wife
or whatever the case may be
it's just not the same thing it looks
the same it feels the same but it's not
and so because of that on one of the
other theta superior spider-man comments
on is of course the view of Mary Jane
Watson everything between the waist and
the neck so I know how to put it but the
cool thing about this is one of the
reasons why I really like superior
spider-man is because of what he tells
her are doing their conversations when
they're kind of going back and forth
when they're talking about the sinister
six and you know where we're superior
spider-man is kind of making the moves
on Mary Jane Watson what he says is that
where he had slashed at overdrive
instead of just scratching him what he
had done is he installed a ton of
nanobots inside of him so that he'd be
able to trace their location and
overhear their conversations and that's
why I say this is so cool because you
wouldn't really see this in a spider-man
story and so it's just kind of
revolutionising and its really like
updating Peter Parker for the modern
times and there are a lot of people will
say well no he doesn't need to be
updated he needs to keep living in the
1960s no I mean seeing him updated here
I think it's actually pretty stellar
seeing new tools that are used new
implementations different things like
that are actually pretty interesting in
terms of how it unfolds and so because
of this he knows exactly where the
sinister six are going to strike he
knows what tactics they're going to use
he knows where they're gonna enter the
building from all that kind of good
stuff
and so because of this as soon as he
encounters the sinister six the second
time he has everything put in place in
order to make sure that he can basically
win to make sure that he can take out
every single one of them and that's
exactly what he does I mean he basically
just defeats them all and so because
that what is up happening as a story or
as a segment begins to wind up is we
actually find out that Peter Parker as
we think of him is not gone is an
innocent irony in fact Peter Parker's
still there he's still in his body the
problem is that P exists in the
subconscious so all he can do is just
watch the things and comment on the
things that superior spider-man is doing
but he can't actually interact with him
he can't actually talk to him directly
now the other half of
is that with regards to superior
spider-man conversing you know with Mary
Jane wants it again you know continuing
to try to keep the idea of this romance
going he's running into the same problem
that Peter Parker always ran into where
he never had any time for his private
life because he was always on patrol
because he was always out doing his own
thing and so what happens is superior
spider-man says well then let's take it
a step further I don't need to be
everywhere I just need to be able to see
everywhere and so what he does is he
takes the concept behind his octobots
which with these little robots but allow
him to monitor things that are going
around the city and carry out his own
schemes and he basically develops spider
BOTS
these are his eyes and ears it allows
him to see everything going on in the
city of New York and it's amazing the
way it unfolds I mean to me that's such
a genius idea why go everywhere we need
to just have these little nano by his
little robots monitoring the city for
you and then respond appropriately now
the funny thing about this is that at
this point he actually asks Mary Jane
Watson on a date and he is terrible at
going on dates like it is it's
disastrous when he takes her on dates
like he tries them he tries to yawn and
put the arm around her move like he he
takes her ballroom dancing I mean dinner
and dancing is always great like dinner
and dancing is always a great way to go
on a date I mean you know if you have a
great meal you have your conversation
and then you just have fun by going out
and dancing somewhere the problem with
where I live it gets lucky there's all
there is just bars where you going drink
and just get drunk so anyone with you
could pick up at a bar you know it's
probably not a girl that you want to
take home but the fact remains here that
he's not really one you know superior
spider-man it's not really one food
dinner like for dancing and he's one for
dinner but not really for dancing and so
it's kind of funny you know because what
he does is he shifts the mood and
instead of you know dancing with with
Mary Jane Watson what he does is he
actually takes your web slinging and
that's actually a really romantic thing
to do like take a website remember she's
done this before but they know really
done it like together in a way like this
the problem is that when he gets her
back to back to her place he gives shut
down in the worst way because rumor
Peter Parker's old girlfriend Carly
Cooper is friends with Mary Jane Watson
and the two like she's basically invited
Carly Cooper over to hang out with her
when the night is over and so it's
basically like sorry superior spider-man
but you got to go home alone too
that's such and so the crazy thing about
this is that with Peter Parker basically
watching the entire event unfold
remember as a as a subconscious aspect
of his own body he basically is forced
to follow dr. octopus you know superior
spider-man superior spider-man says well
I don't necessarily have to be with Mary
Jane Watson I can just relive all the
memories of Peter Parker and so Peter as
a subconscious thought has to follow
Doctor Octopus
as he remembers all the times that Peter
and Mary Jane Watson were together every
single intimate moment they ever shared
which is crushing that's a terrible
thing to have to see but at this point
we kind of switch back over to MJ's and
the reason why is because of the fact
that the vulture is basically sent you
know some of his henchmen you know over
towards Mary Jane Watson a more or less
ransacked the place and wreak all kinds
of havoc and things like that of course
Mary Jane Watson is taken by you know
the vultures henchmen and superior
spider-man rescues her but what superior
spider-man goes after the vulture
directly what ends up happening here is
the vulture basically reveals there were
he's used different people for his own
schemes over the years that what he's
done here is he's actually taken or he's
basically using children he's using him
for that for his own ends now he's using
them in terms of like having them carry
out in a furious deeds you know rob
places and commit crimes and things like
that but he does it by giving them like
arcade tokens and stuff which is kind of
funny but it also strikes a chord and in
superior spider-man and the reason why
is because of the fact that when he's
facing off against the vulture that when
one of the vultures henchmen goes to
attack him he hits the hits the henchmen
and realizes that's that is a child the
reason why this is so significant is
because Peter Parker has a subconscious
thought jumps into a memory of Doctor
Octopus and we learned that doctor
octopus's father was an abusive man and
so it's like Doctor Octopus basically
feels like he's becoming his father
abusing children and so because that it
strikes a particular chord in superior
spider-man and he loses it immediately
goes after tooms you know goes after
vulture the other half of this is this
also the idea that he's had enough now
that's why I say superior spider-man I
think is more interesting than Peter
Parker because Peter Parker has fought
these guys time and time again but Peter
Parker's philosophy is that's just the
nature of being a superhero the nature
of being a superhero is you fight bad
guys the bad guys will get free you have
to subdue them you put them in jail they
get free and they go and did they do the
same thing all over again
that's just the nature being the
superhero that's the
price you pay for keeping the streets
clean while also making sure that you do
not fall down the path of being a bad
guy for superior spider-man it's not
that way he is not nearly as tight-knit
as as Peter Parker is he's not nearly as
clean as Peter Parker is he's a lot more
dirty here you know he basically
thrashes he takes Adrian Toomes he takes
a takes vulture throws him into this
spotlight design to basically signal you
know spider-man was a terrible idea when
it was first introduced when superior
spider-man literally chastised Jay jonah
Jameson for doing he's like why would
you make a spotlight that would tell
everybody where you are so they can come
and find you and then like kill you or
kidnap you and hold you for ransom like
that's a stupid idea just like call me
if you need me or something like that he
was kind of a funny exchange between the
two of them but he sends vulture
crashing into this thing where he's just
kind of cut to ribbons and superhero
spider-man does not feel bad about it
you know with carly cooper arriving on
the scene as him basically saying this
is what i'm about like this is I've had
it I've had it up to here with these
guys you know it's time that they be put
away and so what this does is this
transitions over to the next phase which
is really superior spider-man kind of
rounding up these loose ends you know
grabbing these seven henchmen of a
vulture
rounding them up having them you know
thrown to the child services calling it
a day but also the idea that he's also
dead you know dealing with with onme and
the reason why is remember after Aunt
May's injury she's still learning to
walk you know still learning how to use
her legs properly but a cane is gonna be
a necessity for superior spider-man
this is ridiculous he's like why does
she need a cane I'm a genius you know I
will basically create a device that will
hook up to her leg and then she can
control it using her mind and she can
walk just like a normal human being
the issue with this is that Dan Slott
does not forget about the idea of
villains now the idea of dance like he
never really loses track of villains you
know I mean it for him it's always like
there has to be a main villain now again
this is not a terrible thing it's just
for me I would rather than be a little
more emphasis on you know superior
respondent but the great thing is that
we're currently four issues in so with
33 issues running there's all kinds of
emphasis on superior spider-man
especially when we get to animal County
which choose a character that I
absolutely love I love Anna markrony
she's such a great character um what we
end up doing is you basically pick up
with the return of a guy named massacre
now Massacre is a guy named Marcus Lyman
and Marcus Lyman is a guy who basically
sustained an injury to the brain his
wife was killed but he essentially lost
all connection to humanity he doesn't
value life so he's basically like the
Punisher if the Punisher were a bad guy
the Punisher is kind of a bad
but he's like The Punisher if you were a
bad guy and carrying out schemes and
won't fight you guys will see you know
what what kind of things he gets into
but Massacre basically breaks his way
out you know of Ravencroft asylum and
kind of goes in this campaign you know
and we'll find out exactly what it is
that he does but the introduction of Ana
Marconi comes by way of the fact the
superior spider-man is is really angry
because Peter Parker never got his
doctorate he's not actually a doctor
he's just mr. Peter Parker and in the
mind of Doctor Octopus he's like that's
ridiculous Otto Octavius is like why
shouldn't Peter Parker have his
doctorate so the funny thing is
something I hope you're noticing here is
that like Doctor Octopus is basically
making life better for Peter Parker he's
getting his doctorate he's gonna lay the
groundwork for Parker industries massive
worldwide company he's basically setting
the stage for making Peter Parker's life
better in some ways he's making it rough
on others but he's making it in some
ways but you know going into his first
class you know a class with a guy named
uh professor Lemay's because of the fact
that you know superior spider-man's kind
of mouthing off the introduction of Anna
Marconi comes when she gives a superior
spider-man a note saying hey look you
should come tutor with me and I'll help
you get past this class now switching
back over to massacre what is up
happening here is of course superior
spider-man's alerted to what's going on
with the idea that massacred escaped and
so on and so forth but Massacre is
actually holding up a place called
burger town and basically ends up
shooting the place up when one of the
guys tries to alert the cops
what Massacre does is he Engineers his
own escape now this is the cool thing
about this and this is why I say
Massacre is a lot like the Punisher
the Punisher can easily be viewed it's
like just this mindless beast this guy
that just runs around and just shoots
stuff up and that's it that's why I
loved Garth Ennis his Punisher Mac so
much because inmates it puts so much
focus on Punisher as a person it puts so
much focus on him as an individual and
what he's capable that's one of reasons
why I thought it was so significant ah
but what did it have happening with a
Punishers character what is up happening
with Massacre kind of juxtaposing the
two together as the Punisher is very
very capable he's pretty intelligent
he's not genius level but he's
intelligent in terms of military tactics
conventional warfare that kind of thing
massacre is very similar to that in the
sense that he basically engineers his
own escape by taking a woman hostage but
no one knows that that he's taken her
hostage you know no one knows about her
and so because of this superior Spartan
that actually goes - hooah - not the
watcher but one of the members of
horizon lives and says look you develop
facial recognition software
I need that so I could install it into
my spider BOTS and have my spider bot
in the city looking for the face of
massacre yet another instance where
superior spider-man chose to be a lot
more resourceful than Peter Parker so
because of this what we end up doing is
following massacre when he basically you
know drop someone off in the middle of
the city and then blends in you know we
basically says look you go that way
maybe I'll follow you and if I hear you
say anything if I hear you shout out
I'll kill you or I'll just blend into
the city so basically it's kind of
feeding on fear fear of the idea that
this woman may be shot if Massacre is
actually listening and instead he just
kind of wanders off and goes away and so
because there's what we find out is that
the journey of massacre actually takes
them to the place or to the residence of
a woman named Miranda Pullman now the
reason why this matters is because of
the fact that Miranda Pullman is a CEO
of a company called fizzy Cola and the
idea here of Massacre is to basically
just make a whole bunch of money by
having Miranda pay him twelve million
dollars to walk through the streets of
New York murdering people while wearing
her competitors shirt basically creating
bad press for her competitor and so it
is it's just basic it's just money
is all it is it all just comes down to
something pretty simple now of course we
end up having you know Doctor Octopus in
two spots out into the city in order to
monitor everything but this is when we
get into Anna Marconi a smile of her
character so much so animal County when
superior spider-man first encounters her
she's a diminutive woman you know she's
a person of a certain size and so
because of this she basically says look
you know I'm here to tutor you on you
know professor Lemay's class in order to
help you pass and of course the funny
thing about this is that superior
spider-man is like look I didn't come
over here to be tutored I came over here
to stop sending me your texts and we
know this makes sense because we know
that he would easily pass Lemay's class
that's just one of those things worse
like he would easily make it through
there no questions asked but what is up
happening here is anna says no no you
know you're here for a class you know
I'll go ahead and tutor you and every
tutor every every session the 60 minutes
I'm sorry that's that's one hour in a
sixty minutes comes with a home-cooked
meal let me tell you something man
like if a tutor was like hey I'll cook
you dinner and tutor you I would be like
okay like I'm down like even if she's
just telling me stuff I already know you
know I would be like I'm down for a free
home-cooked meal like yeah you know not
only that like because of the fact that
he shows her how intelligent she is she
then turns around and gives him dessert
so he gets a home-cooked meal and
dessert only to find out that the food
is incredibly good so I'm just like wow
what a catch like I would definitely
stick with that chick that's why I love
Anna Marconi because she's just such a
we just such a great interesting unique
character in the realm of what's going
on as a pure spider-man you know she's
just cool and so because that we switch
over to add to Massacre who's just
shooting the place up you know he's
basically just kind of you know firing
bullets in every direction and so on a
somewhat superior spider-man shows up
but this is when he kind of starts to
learn the lessons of Peter Parker and
what I mean by this is when Peter Parker
first became you'll really first develop
the powers of spider-man the death of
Uncle Ben is what led him to become a
hero to make sure that nobody else
wanted the same experience that he did
the death of Gwen Stacy taught Peter
Parker that he can't be reckless that he
has to pay attention to the things that
he's doing that even if he doesn't mean
to people can die by his own actions and
so because of this Peter Parker again as
a subconscious thought in the mind of
his own body is basically try and heal
screaming to Doctor Octopus you have to
stop this fight now Doctor Octopus gets
kind of carried away a little bit but
even then he begins to learn when other
people are being killed while he's still
present he begins to learn what's going
on now what are you done is he had
basically used his BOTS and realized
that there were individuals who were
being held hostage by Massacre and that
was part of massacres plan was to have
five or six individuals in a warehouse
covered with incendiary devices and that
if superior spider-man showed up he
would detonate those devices and kill
them now because of these BOTS superior
spider-man was able to deactivate these
incendiary devices free those
individuals and so now Massacre has no
back-up plan
the other half of this is superior
spider-man shoots Massacre shoots him in
the shoulder and so the idea is that you
know Peter Parker you know is this
incorporeal thought this subconscious
thought says look that's not how we do
things we don't kill people that's the
price we pay for being a hero we have to
let the bad guys go to prison we have to
let them live we have to let them serve
their debt to society and if they escape
then we have to go track them down and
it's just a really really cool exchange
here because of the fact this appears
spider-man has to come to grips with
this he even addresses this even says
look it would be so easy to just kill
this guy that's what creates an
interesting case here because you know
it's it's like the idea of repeat
offenders if everybody who committed a
crime was killed people would say well
but that's not going to deter people
from committing crimes well it's not
meant to it's just to eliminate repeat
offenders a person can't commit a crime
again if they're dead and that's the
philosophy their superior spider-man
takes here like if this guy goes to
prison and he gets out he'll be a repeat
offender but if I kill him then the
number of crimes goes
by that much so you know why let this
guy live but ultimately he basically
slides and says I can't do it you know
not only that Massacre more or less is
forced to feel fear now that part of the
story is is interesting for what it is I
mean it's not a wildly relevant it's
kind of a way to to bring it to a close
but it's basically superior spider-man
saying there's only one way that this
can it there's only one way that this
can come to a close and all we see is a
shot being fired and so the indication
is given to us here is that with this
shot being fired superior spider-man
just killed Massacre and that's what
makes this kind of wild is because
superior spider-man's kind of a murderer
now and that that's what makes it so
unique so that's so interesting to me
but ultimately this whole segment wraps
up when he has his BOTS basically travel
over to to Pullman and say look I know
what you did I know you about your
secret bank account I know that you paid
Massacre to do what he did you are the
hand behind murder and so you know we
don't necessarily see what happens to
her he says either you can go to the
police and tell them what you've done or
you can answer to me and I will kill you
and so that's the interesting thing
about this is because it's superior
spine I'm basically saying I will kill
if it's necessary if it means preserving
the life of other people then I will
kill him I will kill him if it means I
can spare countless other individuals
then I will murder a person okay so
getting into a superior spider-man
volume to this again is where Dan Slott
kind of ghost is this phase of kind of
taking things in steps taking things in
small oval portions here and there
really what's superior for a spider-man
first started almost as superior Iron
Man which I really want to cover that
story at some point but when superior
spider-man first started there were a
lot of thoughts of people saying well
spider-man's gonna come back Peter
Parker is going to come back to normal
ease gonna come back to being himself
and he is I mean you can't do something
like superior spider-man and get rid of
Peter Parker forever he's to intrinsic
of a superhero it'd be like killing off
Superman and never bringing him back
because of that we knew that Spiderman
was going to come back later on down the
line but in the interim Dan Slott and
Marvel were playing this up as though
Peter Parker was gone forever and so
what we had this subconscious aspect of
Peter Parker in the mind of his own body
despite the fact that Doctor Octopus was
basically taking control of Peter's body
in the end what the story's going to do
is basically eliminate that entire idea
and bring forward the notion that Peter
Parker is gone forever now the way this
initially picks up is it actually joins
us with a guy named doctor
wertham who also goes by the name of
cardiac now cardiac is a guy who dates
all the way back to amazing spider-man
number 342 in 1990 when in truth it was
really just like Elias wertham he didn't
really become cardiac until like three
two or three issues later some long
those lines but the idea here was that
he was basically a vigilante but not in
the traditional sense and that's one of
the things that made his characters
interesting cardiac was actually a guy
who took the law into his own hands for
the betterment of society and so what he
was doing is he was basically fighting
against criminals he was fighting
against guys like Justin Hammer
different things like that so he wasn't
really like a traditional bad guy or
traditional antihero like the Punisher
he was actually doing good things the
idea here though is that Elias wertham
is basically taking over the heart
clinic now this is one of the reasons
why I wanted to do really you know
spider-man big time going forward
because of the fact that a lot of things
that were taking place in superior
spider-man referenced the events of Big
Time and some of them even referenced
some of the events before but really big
time is all we needed since the bulk of
the references really come from dance
lots first time taking over the series
as a solo guy but the idea here is that
Elias wertham is basically running this
sort of underground Hospital and that's
kind of cool here because what we end up
finding out from the perspective of
Elias wertham one of the big issues with
modern-day hospitals is cost the idea
that people go in they have pre-existing
conditions yada yada yada and it's
really dance last way of saying this is
the biggest problem with society at the
moment is that you have people who need
legitimate medical attention but they're
basically knocked down on the donors
list because they have existing
conditions or because they're just not
as high up somebody registered before
them and it's really just one of these
ideas where it is a lot of people need
more help then there is help this
actually available and so because of
this we end up finding out that Elias
wertham has been going through and
launching these little attacks where
he's basically been stealing supplies
from places in order to provide his
people with the help that they need
but these supplies that are being stolen
our supplies that were confiscated from
criminals so it actually kind of begs an
interesting question is he really doing
the wrong thing or is he doing the right
thing or is he doing the right thing for
all the wrong reason I'm sorry is he
doing uh doing the wrong thing for all
the right reasons so because of this
again it kind of throws us in a moral
quandary and that's one of the things
that I love so much about Dan Slott
superior spider-man is it really brings
a lot of moral philosophical ideals into
the equation when we talked about that
in the last video when superior
spider-man
massacre if you kill one man to save a
thousand people is it the right thing to
do it's it's good old-fashioned Jeremy
Bentham
you know John Stuart Mill utilitarianism
the sacrifices are I guess the the needs
of the many outweigh the needs of the
few but the the moral implication here
is at what point does that stop you know
we saw that with like Superman for
example topple the governments of the
world so the billions of people who
exist can live without the oppression of
government so again you know there's
there's a point at which you simply just
have to stop and that's when it comes to
the whole philosophy of you know
morality and so on and so forth it's
really the line draw now of course
because of the actions of of Elias
because of his actions you know is
cardiac breaking in a facility so on and
so forth stealing the things that he
needs what this does is it basically has
you know the the police for New York
investigating or at least alerting
alerting superior spider-man now
Whittier lives on the scene right off
the bat he immediately attacks
Elias now again Peter Parker exists as
the sort of subconscious thought and
occasionally he can intervene and what
this will actually show us as he can
still influence the body and even the
mind of a superior spider-man but
because of this Peter Parker's screaming
in the background look this guy is not a
bad guy he's doing all the right things
or all the wrong things for all the
right reasons but he's trying to do good
he's trying to do what he's supposed to
and so because this the first indication
that we get of Peter Parker being able
to influence a Peter a superior
spider-man is when he screams to stop
and it just catches the attention of
superior spider-man now again these are
disembodied voices in the mind of
superior spider-man he doesn't know
what's going on all he's hearing is just
a voice somewhere telling him to stop
we'll also see here in a little while
that it'll actually a Peter Parker will
start moving his own hand at different
things like that but again this is
basically just a I guess an effect of
the two of them fighting one another but
when we end up finding out that Elias is
here to basically steer some steel
something called the neurologic scanner
which is designed to basically map the
human brain superior spider-man realizes
that as Doctor Octopus he made that
device and so in his mind
cardiac is stealing something that
inherently belongs to Doctor Octopus now
this is a funny situation because what
this does is it throws into sharp relief
the idea that despite the fact that
Doctor Octopus took over the body of
Peter Parker and is now operating as
spider-man he can't quite let his pass
to go he can't quite let go of the fact
that
he was a bad guy the things that he
invented if this was a wholesale
relaunch if this was a wholesale idea of
dr. octopus walking away from his past
he would simply say well you can have it
that's just mine that's my past life but
the fact that he feels like it still
belongs to him means he simply can't let
that go now from here it is the idea of
him trying to figure out what's going on
inside of his own mind and the idea that
Peter Parker had basically stayed his
hand despite the fact that superior
spider-man was going to kill cardiac and
so at this point it's basically superior
spider-man tagging cardiac with one of
these you know little spider trackers so
he can track his location as well as
superior spider-man going back and see
if he can't figure out what's going on
with his own body now what is up
happening here is in the middle of his
investigations he's basically contacted
by the Avengers now this is actually
kind of a funny situation because it's
basically superior spider-man versus the
Avengers and what Dan Slott did with
this is he designed this explicitly I
really wrote this explicitly for the
purpose to show us how spider-man would
stack up against the Avengers because we
haven't really had a reason to see a
story where he takes on the entirety of
the offenders because smiley has always
been a good guy he's always been a guy
that fought on behalf of the Avengers
but he never really fought against them
at least not as a person who was
literally trying to do them harm and so
because of this the Avengers basically
call him in and say look we've been
watching the things that you've done
you've taken a far heavier hand with
villains and you have in the past you
killed Massacre you almost killed
cardiac what is going on with you now of
course because of the fact that they
basically want to take him and conduct a
full scan a whole battery of tests the
fear of superior spider-man as the
Avengers we'll figure out what's going
on with him then it'll actually figure
out that Doctor Octopus took over the
body of Peter Parker and so of course
this leads to a skirmish between these
members of the Avengers sapir spiraling
himself now keep in mind this is not
like a full contingent of the Avengers
but the ones who were here nothing to
laugh at I mean you've got Wolverine
with his heightened senses Captain
America with his agility you have four
you have Jessica drew Spider Woman I
mean you have some pretty formidable
guys here and of course Black Widow I
don't want to leave I don't want to
leave Black Widow out but what is up
happening here is there's basically
reference made to the idea that Peter
Parker I'm sorry that superior
spider-man I'm so used to saying Peter
Parker that superior spider-man's
spider-sense makes it almost impossible
for the Avengers to take him out and
that's the me that I want to kind of
talk about here for a second really in
my mind for the longest time and Sal
overcoming pop
tell you this the longest time I always
thought Peter Parker was just a stupid
character like I never liked spider-man
I was like hey look he's popular people
like him whatever I don't really care
but you know after really analyzing him
further and going through these stories
in the end as well written as a lot of
these stories are one of the reasons why
Peter Parker you know asked spider-man
and even super you know Doctor Octopus a
superior spider-man one of the reasons
why you know he's such a formidable hero
is because of the fact that his spider
sense basically alerts him of danger
before that danger ever happens so he's
always a step ahead of the person that
he's fighting one of the best ways to
look at this is that the the best
offense is a good defense and so because
of this you know with superior
spider-man having the ability to know
attacks that are going to happen before
they happen even if he doesn't know
exactly what the attacking person is
going to do it keeps him out of harm's
way and so what this means is he can
turn around and routinely stay on the
offensive so long as his spider sense is
working adequately now of course you
know in a moment of distraction when
Peter Parker is basically distracting
Doctor Octopus what this does is it
grants the Avengers a brief moment of
reprieve which of course were able to
use to essentially topple him but at
this point Dan Slott kind of makes the
Avengers look like buffoons which is not
something that I'm really really on par
with I mean I love The Avengers I mean
the Avengers one of my favorite teams
but to make them look like buffoons it's
not something that I'm but I'm too
partial with but basically what what
happens is after all these different
tests Captain America says we've
confirmed you're not a scroll you're not
possessed by you know some ghost out in
space somewhere no one's taking control
of you or anything like that but in the
moment of analyzing these brain patterns
Doctor Octopus realizes that there's
brain patterns that should not be there
now he doesn't know that it's Peter
Parker all he knows is his brain the
patterns are not where they're supposed
to be and so because of this you know
while Natasha Romanoff is having this
conversation with superior spider-man
talking about the first time she killed
and how you know the fact that superior
spider-man had killed Massacre is going
to stick with him whether he knows it or
not Peter Parker takes control of doctor
octopus's hand while he's kind of idle
and basically draws out this little
diagram indicating that's that Doctor
Octopus stole the bus or the body of
Peter Parker now the problem with this
is that this is a very basic drawing and
Dan Slott plays it up this way Dan Slott
plays its plays it up to us you know so
that we look at this and we're like well
how in the heck is she supposed to know
that Doctor Octopus took control of
Peter Parker's body you know but at the
very least it would it would send often
into
that there's something legitimately
wrong with spider-man and so because of
this you know a natasha romanoff rule of
course would be able to put two and two
together eventually what this will do is
kind of set her as or at least a bid
sentence it's the possibility up that
she's going to end up on this course or
she's gonna start investigating what's
actually going on with Peter Parker now
switching back over to to cardiac of
course with dr. octopus superior
spider-man using the spider tracker and
eventually you know locating what he's
at the two of them engage in a skirmish
once more but in the middle of this
whole fight basically it leads into this
operating room and this is when superior
spider-man begins to realize that the
reason why cardiac is doing this is to
save the lives of people and so the the
whole crux of this was that despite the
fact that he had taken a scanner from
you know that had previously been built
by dr. octopus cardiac did not know how
to use it in its entirety and so what
this does is it basically sets the stage
for Dan Slott to continue superior
spider-man down the role of being a good
guy when he looks at this and says well
I'm the one who designed this machine I
know how it works better than anybody
else I can literally help fix this girl
and I can turn around and perform the
surgery myself and so of course again
because of the fact that this has
completed the little girl is saved
it basically continues this trend of
superior spider-man becoming a good guy
and so taking that machine back to his
lab and then investigating further he
directly acknowledges Peter Parker he
says look I now realize you're the voice
inside my head I now realize that I
didn't take over your body in its
entirety that you know for some reason
or another your consciousness is still
there now after doing a little more
investigating after that what we find
out is that the this essence of Peter
Parker that's talking to dr. octopus is
basically an amalgamation of his
memories in the sense that as long as
dr. octopus uses the memories of Peter
Parker Peter Parker's essence will
always be there and this is really Dan
Slott essentially saying that we as
people are effectively just a
combination of all our experiences
everything that makes us who we are are
the things that we've been through and
so because of that Peter will always be
alive so long as his memories aren't
there and so dr. octopus takes the most
logical step and simply says we have to
purge these memories from my mind now
this was actually a really really really
cool segment of the story because this
pits Peter Parker and dr. octopus
against one another in a way that hasn't
really been seen before routinely
speaking when these guys go against one
another they just kind of fight I mean
it's really just a fight in the city and
on for a little while and then innocents
are put in danger you know Peter Parker
defeats Doctor Octopus Doctor Octopus
goes away for a little while he manages
to break out and then it starts all over
again
it's pretty out par for the course you
can set your watch to the fights between
Peter Parker and his rogues gallery but
what this does is it introduces a new
dynamic because what they're doing is
they're fighting inside the mind of
Peter Parker's body and so what this
does is it creates a pretty even playing
field between the two of them a Peter
Parker basically draws on all the people
who have served significant roles in his
life Uncle Ben Aunt May friends and
family different things like that and
while this does allow him to get a
little bit of the upper hand
it is Dan Slott saying a little bit Hey
look the most important thing that we
have in life are friends and family but
the other half of this equation is that
doctor Doctor Octopus himself is not
without his own friends now when I say
friends of Doctor Octopus when I say
family of Doctor Octopus I used that
term loosely these various villains that
that aqus fought behind or fought beside
over the course of the years I wouldn't
really consider to be like legitimate
friends or legitimate family not by any
stretch of the imagination but they're
the closest thing he has not only that
all these guys are formidable in their
own right and so in truth it comes down
to a pretty significant battle between
the two of them but in the end Doctor
Octopus ends up winning out now the
reason why this is the case is twofold
the first is that it is people with
superpowers going against individuals
without superpowers but this is also Dan
Slott offering a meta commentary that
the people fighting on be the on behalf
of Peter Parker are only as strong as
Peter Parker is for himself that is to
say they're a reflection of the faith
that Peter Parker has it himself only if
he is a strong individual only if he
legitimately believes that he should be
spider-man do these individuals have any
measure of power to combat Doctor
Octopus but in the end he doesn't think
that he deserves to be spider-man and
the reason why is because of a
conversation between the two of them as
this fight starts to dwindle down and it
just turns into superior spider-man
versus the amazing spider-man Doctor
Octopus makes an incredibly good point
what happened here was that when when
when superior spider-man was in the
process of getting ready to perform the
surgery on that young girl Peter Parker
did not want him to do it he kept making
his handshake and the reason why was
because Peter Parker did not believe
that Doctor Octopus would have the skill
to save this young girl's life what
Doctor Octopus says here is you were
willing to let this girl die in order to
get your body back you are willing to
sacrifice an innocent in order to deceit
in order to defeat me Doctor Octopus
making the case that what Peter Parker
did was tantamount to Doctor Octopus
holding someone hostage and then Peter
Parker shooting the hostage in order to
kill Doctor Octopus that's the case
that's being made here and because of
that in in face of that Peter Parker has
a total breakdown he says oh my god
you're right I was willing to sacrifice
the life of an innocent young girl in
order to make sure that you were
defeated that you were stopped the other
half of this was that Doctor Octopus
says look I was trying to do the right
thing so not only were you willing to
put an innocent in danger you were going
to stop me from doing something good you
were going to become a bad guy because
you didn't like what it was that I was
doing you didn't trust me and so because
of this Doctor Octopus basically
initiates this Mindwipe a Peter Parker
has no no more defence really nothing to
put up against this and so all these
different memories of Peter Parker start
getting wiped away and what this does is
it sets the next stage in the next phase
of the story which is simply Doctor
Octopus in the body of Peter Parker
without having to worry about his
essence or his memories causing any kind
of problems for him in the foreseeable
future okay so continuing on with
superior spider-man we're officially
into the story without Peter Parker and
it's actually kind of cool here I mean
Peter Parker's cool and everything but
the idea of doing a story where Doctor
Octopus takes over the body of Peter
Parker is something that I'd like to see
focused on strictly as him without
influence from Peter Parker and Dan
Slott gives us that I mean this first
issue is actually called independence
you know Independence Day because he's
basically free of the control of Peter
Parker at least the influence of Peter
Parker now the cool thing about this is
it allows Dan Slott to set the stage for
everything in all-new all-different
amazing spider-man because remember you
have superior spider-man the whole run
33 issues you've got spider-verse and
which spider-verse doesn't wasn't really
necessary it's kind of a cool story but
it's not really necessary by any
standard of measurement it's almost
completely and totally self-contained
and then you have two story arcs from
Amazing Spiderman and then all-new
all-different marvel happens so again
it's pretty cool in terms of how all
this just segues directly into the
current run of amazing spider-man under
Dan Slott congas fear sea and all that
kind of good stuff
but what this does is it shows us how
streamlined
[ __ ] has made a spider-man's life
remember he's got all these little
spider eyes that are walking around well
because of that they literally keep an
eye on New York and tell him everything
that's happening and so when he wakes up
in the morning he gets daily briefings
on what's happening what villains are
fighting one another which ones are
worth their attention and which ones
aren't now the funny thing about this is
Doc Ock talks about how in this
circumstance Peter Parker would have
just thrown on the spider-man costume
and would have just jumped into the fray
because of this he says I'm not going to
take that role instead I'm gonna let
them deplete their ranks I'm gonna let
them fight each other to the point that
they can't fight anymore and then I'm
gonna go in and I'm gonna take things
over it's classic Napoleon Bonaparte
that's really what it is Napoleon
Bonaparte was well known that go into
countries start civil wars when they're
at their weakest conquer them it's the
smartest way to conduct yourself in
terms of taking over a hostile entity
and that's exactly what he does here
he's like look if I want to defeat these
guys I could go in and just fight them
all but the problem is I may or may not
win and it would just be a waste of time
what I can do is just let them keep
fighting each other until the point that
their forces are to the point of
exhaustion when that happens I'll go in
and just take everybody over and that's
exactly what happens is like nobody does
he goes in and of course attacks like
owl man you know and a handful of others
but the other thing that I want to point
out here is how strong is Spider Man is
when I was going through spider-man
number seven number 700 we were going
through like you know die anguish and
suicide run and all those stories that
led up to superior spider-man one of the
things that I wanted to hold off on
talking about was the idea of how strong
spider-man is now Sal over a comic pop
has done several videos on my channel
which you'll find down the description
well we run over spider-man stuff and
then Sal is one of the four most
knowledgeable people about spider-man
that I've ever met it's literally his
bread and butter like it's it's crazy
how knowledgeable he is about spider-man
but historically speaking there's been
references to Peter Parker pulling his
punches but it easy spider-man numbers
number 700 Doctor Octopus confirmed that
and that's the significance of those
kind of things in color books it's one
thing for a character to say I'm really
powerful it's another for other
characters to say yes they are really
powerful to confirm it by virtue of
another character gives it a little more
substance now again it's just whatever
the writers want it to be and so take it
for what it is but the fact remains here
that with Doctor Octopus plotting
against scorpion in superior spider-man
I'm sorry in a amazing spider-man number
number 700 he punched him in the jaw so
hard that he knocked his jaw
that's when dr. octopus realized how
strong Peter Parker is and that s
spider-man he basically been pulling his
punches the entire time now the reason
why that was significant is because what
it means is going forward in this story
of the stories before it as part of
superior spider-man is a Doc Ock had to
recognize how easy it would be for him
to kill foes as one of the first things
that the Peter Parker started to realize
in the alternate universe
is the first thing he realized to his
detriment when he killed a person so
because this is it's really kind of cool
to see it all unfold but again
one of the other things going on behind
the scenes here is the return of Norman
Osborn really as the Green Goblin I'll
keep in mind Norman Osborn has and
always will be
a spider-man villain but he had a lot of
a lot of you know really promotion and a
lot of exposure to the larger couple of
a community and Marvel went during the
events of a Dark Reign when he became
the director of shield now I don't know
what was going on behind the scenes
ayman able to find any interviews to
verify but I don't know anything going
on behind the scenes in terms of whether
or not this was all design the whole
Dark Reign story was all designed to
bolster the reputation of Norman Osborn
so that when goblin Nation happened that
it would be a lot more interesting I
don't really know if that's the case or
not
the only thing that I can really guess
here is that because of the fact that
Norman Osborn is essentially going to
claim himself as the Goblin King you
know go way as I guess really as part of
lead up to goblin nation that it was
just really part of a scheme to kind of
reinvigorate his character but again
this could entirely be self-contained
too it could just be the Dan Slott
didn't care anything about Dark Reign
and they just said you know what we're
gonna read they have the one Osborn and
we're gonna make a matte Goblin King
instead of the Green Goblin I have no
real idea here but the fact remains that
switching back over to doc ock is
spider-man again a lot of this deals
with him and his personal relationships
it's actually funny watching him talk to
people because of the fact that he
usually just talks down to them and it's
not like I mean I don't think it's funny
to talk down to people but it's funny in
terms of how he does it in the sense
he's talking to the professor you know
the person before is Forest thesis and
he's like man this guy's a buffoon and
he talks to him that way like he
literally finishes his test takes it
over hands it in and says don't bother
worrying about it i H the whole thing
you don't have to check it but you can
if you want but if you did you just be
wasting your time so it's it's funny
they kind of see him interacting that
way but again you know with regards to
Goblin King bolstering his ranks he's
basically grabbing all these different
individuals use different henchman part
of these small-time criminals or just
petty thieves or what-have-you and
having them operate as part of his
scheme and
to essentially try to take over New York
now again a lot of this is leading up to
goblin nation so it's just these pages
here and there you know we're some small
things happen with regards to to the
green Goblin's but what is up happening
here is some of these goblins attack
Mary Jane Watson nightclub this whole
attack coincides with dinner that a
Spider Man is having with Anna Maria and
I remember Anna Maria is part of all-new
all-different marvel she's a woman of a
diminutive size but she's also really
interesting and the reason why is
because with her being as intelligent as
she is she doesn't really cook using
conventional methods and in fact what
she's doing is she's making a carbonated
sorbet using dry ice but it's really
cool because they're basically making
ice cream now of course this is great in
and of itself because ice cream isn't
anytime you like you can have ice cream
any time that's one of the great things
that I love about ice cream my personal
favorite is cookies and cream I wonder
what your personal favorite is I love
cookies and cream print is a cream isn't
bad chocolate chip ice cream is terrible
chocolate chip mint is even worse but I
love cookies and cream but what this
does is it sets the stage for romance
between the two of them and the reason
why is because when the dry ice is
dropped you know of course spider-man
reaches in grabs it and just kind of
lets it go realizing you know that it
hurts him but annamaria kind of patches
him up and the two of them share a kiss
now this is cool because with the
character of Anna Maria what she's going
to do is begin the process of
transitioning Doctor Octopus away from
being a bad guy and in fact almost the
entirety of his motivation with regards
to you know all-new all-different marvel
and awesome is going to be rooted in his
love for Anna Maria so that's the
coolest thing about this one of the
things that I really dig about that but
again it's also a dance lot messing with
the idea of Mary Jane Watson finding
love of her own wind the entire incident
with the the the attack on her nightclub
the resulting fire and so on is met by a
fire department and she comes across a
guy named Pedro so again you know dance
la it's kind of coin where this notion
of the two of them going their own
separate ways I mean it's already
established at this point by virtue of
the things that he's written into the
story that you know superior spider-man
and Mary Jane Watson are never going to
get together but the other half of this
is again the way that the entire
spider-man process has been streamlined
the fire department showing up at Mary
Jane Watson severed Mary Jane wasas
business came by way of superior
spider-man because of the fact that he's
aware of everything going on that's been
going on with the city in his mind he
was arguing well why not have my own
life and keep the city safe and that's
exactly what he did when the when the
attack happened when the fire broke out
he basically had the fire department
notified and they responded now of
course the bigger question to ask here
is what would Peter Parker have done and
Peter Parker would have arrived he would
have left
annamaria he would have arrived on the
scene and the reason why is because he
wouldn't know whether or not people were
going to die in the fire and that's one
of the issues with regards to superior
spider-man in terms of how he views
himself as spider-man I mean it's no
secret by now
he's a much darker character and because
of his willingness to kill something
that will actually see yet again I hear
in this story in his mind you know the
needs of the many outweigh the needs of
the few so sure one person might die in
that fire
but if seven people are saved well then
that's just the way it goes and so again
it's kind of a darker road to take for
his character but it's one of the
reasons that I kind of find a little
refreshing here man
you know Peter Parker spider-man is the
spider-man it'll always be that way
but for me Doctor Octopus is superior
spider-man mix a little more interesting
mix a little more you know a little more
visceral in terms of how somebody with
his mind would operate in a position
like that now of course at this point we
transition over to Jay jonah Jameson
with the execution of Spider Slayer now
keep in mind we talked about this when
we first started spider-man big time we
had spires later I'm sorry spiders later
Alastair Smythe who again it basically
attacked spider-man but it resulted in
the death of Marla Jameson J John
Jameson's wife and so because of this
Alastair Smythe is getting ready to
undergo execution but the khalsa
spider-man comes by way of the fact that
J John Jameson believes that that Smythe
is going to have some contingency plan
in place in order to allow him to break
free now of course all of this is taking
place on the raft which is a maximum
security prison for supervillains really
like the raft had his biggest claim to
fame when electro engineered a mass
breakout at the start of New Avengers
when Brian Michael Bendis first took
over the title really when the title was
first launched to be honest I mean it
was this inaugural story the raft which
is really really cool and then after
that it was who is this century like new
Avenger he's really good for a little
while and then it just kind of dropped
off but it was pretty solid you know in
the beginning ah but the fact remains
here that the the relationships between
superior spider-man and all the other
people that he knows are predicated on
how he views himself in relation to them
and so there's a lot of arrogance
there's a lot of not really cruelty but
there's a lot of the belief that he's
simply better than they are just by
virtue of his intelligence now the other
half of this is that this is Doctor
Octopus in the body of Peter Parker
which means that was Alastair Smith
getting ready to undergo his execution
that basically his little spider the
Spider Slayer BOTS immediately
infiltrated the place and start ripping
things up but Doctor Octopus was ready
for it all and that's why I say I think
he's better than Peter Parker because
Peter Parker basically flies by the seat
of his pants as spider-man now for Peter
Parker fans
that's the endearing part of it that's
the reason why they love him is because
of the fact that you never know what's
gonna happen he doesn't even know what's
gonna happen
he's quick on his toes he has to think
fast he jumps into a situation uses his
intelligence combined with a spider
sense and his abilities in order to try
to get the situation to bend to his
favorite with Doctor Octopus it's a lot
more methodical it's a lot more planning
but I would say it's also a much better
implementation of spider-man I mean
let's say for example that Peter Parker
took the steps the superior spider-man
did where he basically had spider BOTS
all throughout the city imagine how much
safer New York would be with Peter
Parker using that method but of course
again superior spider-man was one that
came up with it to basically streamline
the process now in truth this was really
dance la to me as you know as we kind of
continue to this fight this was really
Dan Slott basically saying hey look this
is the basis behind what we'll see an
all-new all-different marvel this
spider-man process was streamlined
because superior spider-man made it so
and so what it meant was that when Peter
Parker finally got his body back he
benefited from all the work of superior
spider-man so that's when the reasons
why it's so cool but again Doc Ock
basically cuts off almost every single
rat of escape for Alastair Smith but the
other half of this is that with superior
spider-man having you know destroyed the
jaw of scorpion you know having fought
off against guys you know like vulture
and so on what this does is it sets the
stage for them gaining their own revenge
and is basically this idea that his own
ghosts are coming back to haunt him now
this is really just kind of you know Dan
Slott throwing us in there for the sake
of having in there it's not bad it's
just kind of cool to see but it's really
more of a message about consequence it's
more of a message about the fact that
whenever it is that the Doc Ock goes
through an action superior spider-man
and Exmouth there will be fall back
there will be splash over there will be
consequences for his actions and so of
course the cool thing about this is that
you know one of the box basically
appears so like Norah Winters who works
in the Daily Bugle Jay jonah Jameson
most of these individuals who were there
to observe the execution and
just kind of watched everything go awry
in superior spider-man shows up with a
pre-recorded message essentially saying
look I've planned for this I figured
this was gonna happen I'm going to
create a a bubble that's going to keep
you protected
do not leave or you will put yourself in
danger which of course j jonah Jameson
leaves because it's Jo Jameson but I
would also say this is probably one of
the best moments of his character and
there isn't wise because with superior
spider-man and Alastair Smythe fighting
one another
basically jenna jameson shows up in a
guards outfit and manages to offer a
distraction but of course in the
meantime you know we really have
spider-man dealing with like you know
scorpion and dealing with vulture and so
on you know and he's able to hold off
his own yummy is able to do pretty well
ah but then we also have doc Connors
being freed from itself when Alistair
Smythe takes power down to the to the
facility now keep in mind we talked
about about doc Connors but historically
speaking lizards always just been a
villain of spider-man he was driven more
by like impulse and instinct and you
know whose desire to kill spider-man
more so than anything else but we had
talked during real really doing big Tom
in the events leading up to superior
spider-man that Doc Connors the Connors
persona had basically taken over it had
been quite some time since he was the
you know that the notable villain that
we'd all known the guy who just kind of
ripped things up instead you know he was
very much himself and so where he would
be freed and we would think he would
join in the fray against superior
spider-man he actually doesn't instead
he basically fights as a good guy
because it is doc Connors
fighting you know with the doc Connors
mind and so because of this in the minor
superior spider-man Alistair Smythe
represents just incorrigibility the fact
that Smythe will not stop until he kills
J jonah Jameson basically continues his
campaign of eliminating everybody that
he simply just doesn't like or that has
harmed him in some form or fashion and
so where we end up having scorpion a
timming to attack J jonah Jameson we am
having doc Connors jump into the fray
now this is what you really really cool
to see and the reason why was because
when it comes to the different foes of
spider-man spider-man has some of the
most recognizable villains and comic
book come and pop made a really good
point about that during an episode of
the weekly cool about how spider-man has
some of the most notable villains in the
realm of comic books I mean I would say
that like Doctor Octopus you know
scorpion venom carnage those are some of
the most popular villains to have ever
appeared I mean you have guys like
Lex Luthor you know in Darkseid who are
always going to be you know at the very
very top you know you've got guys like
the Joker who is who is at the very top
if you look at almost every single list
of the most popular villains to ever
existed but spider-man always has a very
popular rogues gallery the difference
here is this is not Peter Parker facing
off against these guys this is Doctor
Octopus but to have doc Connors aligning
himself with Jay jonah Jameson fighting
against the scorpion it's a cool thing
it's actually a really interesting turn
of events to see and so because of this
you know essentially doc Connors
overpowers scorpion in the extreme I
mean there's really no contest here he
absolutely wrexham and the reason why is
because it's just so much organic
strength and lizard himself and so it's
really kind of a funny situation to see
but the fact remains here you know
jumping back over to two superior
spider-man because of the fact that
these bots are essentially being made to
fail because they're being engineered
and being shut down what it means is
that the various abilities of these you
know different guys are effectively
going away vultures going back to being
a blind guy you know so on and so forth
they're not nearly as capable as they
were a second ago so again with
everything effectively having come to an
end with them all having been defeated
Alastair Smyth makes one last-ditch
effort to try to destroy superior
spider-man but in truth he's fighting on
fumes and he's got he's really got
nothing left and so superior spider-man
essentially takes him out and kills him
he basically says look we're Alastair
Smyth intended to basically switch
bodies with superior spider-man in the
same way the Doctor Octopus switched
bodies of Peter Parker Doc Ock says no
that's the first thing that any villain
facing off against me would try to do is
take over my body if they have any
measure of intelligence he says I
planned for that but then what he also
does is in his dying moments superior
spider-man reveals that he's actually
Doc Ock to Alastair Smythe and so again
basically bringing his body back up and
essentially saying this guy is dead he's
not gonna bother us anymore
what he does is on the way back to the
island Peter spider-man reveals to Jay
John Jameson that he recorded a
conversation between the two of them and
in this conversation Jay jonah Jameson
had stated look Alastair Smythe was
supposed to be here for his execution I
want you to make sure that happens when
superior spider-man asked the question
are you asking me to kill Alistair
Smythe J jonah jameson more or less said
yes and so because the fact that this
conversation was recorded
what is up happening in superior
spider-man says you're the mayor of New
York you're going to
give me the raft you're going to shut it
down and you're gonna give it to me if
you don't I'm going to issue this
broadcast out to the world and everybody
is going to see that the mayor of New
York City Jay jonah Jameson had
sanctioned the murder of a villain and
so again this basically kind of sets
things back to familiarity and the sense
that Jay jonah Jameson is like I hate
you again spider-man I hate you now I
absolutely despise you now like you are
you're a terrible thing but the reason
why superior spider-man did this is
because of the fact that with the raft
is simply having its doors closed and
him taking over it doesn't give J John
Jameson or anybody any time to take out
everything that's in there and so
essentially you have superior spider-man
Wow with access to military-grade
technology and weapons and so again what
it does is it allows him to up the ante
in terms of his role as spider-man and
move things in a direction of taking
even more of a militaristic approach
than he previously has in the story so
far okay
so continuing our whole thing about
secure spider-man this is when we
actually delve into you know really
spider-man 2099 now who's gonna be the
kicker develop this whole thing there's
gonna be the craziness is like the
middle of the story there's going to be
like a singular moment that takes place
in the story and it's gonna be one panel
and then another panel between those two
panels the entirety of spider-verse
takes place and it's kind of crazy the
way the Dan Slott did but it was still
really really cool and we'll cross that
bridge when we get to it but what we do
here is we actually picked up with wave
on New York which is it I'm sorry New
York which is based in New York in the
year 2099 um but what I want to do here
is I want to have a little bit of a
discussion about Miguel O'Hara
spider-man 2099 now this version of 2099
that we're seeing here is not the
traditional spider-man 2099 universe
instead a section referred to as Earth
9:00 to 8:00 and remember whatever it
comes to futures in Marvel Comics so to
say you know 20 years from now or a
hundred years from now or something like
that those usually always consider to be
like you know alternate realities
usually always considered to be like
dystopian futures or something like that
or sometimes they're enlightened futures
but because of the fact that that future
is not guaranteed Marvel just kind of
chalks it up to an alternate reality now
aspects of that future may be guaranteed
but the future in and of itself in terms
of how we
see it is not guaranteed to happen with
2099 traditionally that is to say the
you know spider-man 2099 1992 Peter
David run what it basically happened is
that there was a massive civil war
between humans and mutants and
eventually it led to the point where the
earth basically experienced this
systemic breakdown of social classes in
the sense that you basically has had
this super rich and then everybody else
and so what it did is it basically
created a very corporatized
environment where there was non-stop
advertising everything was corporate it
was 100% if you weren't rich you were
basically poor and you were living your
life as best you could um the idea here
was that at the time because of the fact
that that heroes like the Spider Man
were really kind of considered to be
archaic they were reminiscent of days
gone by Miguel O'Hara had actually
become part of a group called alchemax
and the idea was that Miguel O'Hara
himself looked to the idea of Spider Man
and then eventually took up the mantle
now this coincided with like a new
generation of superheroes who basically
began rising up but adopted the mantle
of previous people whether they were
villains or anti heroes and so you had
like Punisher 2099 and you have you know
all these different characters that we
knew and loved
but as 2099 counterparts now the truth
be told I've thought about going back
into covering spider-man 2099 I thought
about going back in and covering all
that stuff I mean right now we can't
just because we have so much to do like
we have all this spider-man in
spider-verse and then you know all-new
all-different amazing spider-man and
then we transition over to Thor then we
transition over to the entire Marvel
cosmology and the origin of Thanos and
the remastering of Infinity Gauntlet and
then infinity war and infinity crusade a
million things that we're gonna do
really going in for the next little
while but I may try to find a place to
squeeze in spider-man 29 because Miguel
is a really really cool character I
really love what he brings to the
superhero landscape but the fact remains
here that we really just kind of join
him in the aftermath of the age of
Ultron and that's where the future that
we're seeing right now that's where that
hails from one of the big questions a
lot of people had is like how did
Galactus from like the main Marvel
Universe cross over into the ultimate
universe you know what was going on with
y'all spin universe doing the collapse
of the multiverse all that kind of stuff
so that kind of sidetrack here for a
second away from this this spider-man
story and bear with me here because
we're gonna we're gonna jump back into
it when Marvel is basically setting the
stage for the collapse of the multiverse
and basically going into Hickman's whole
Avengers a new Avenger
and all that kind of stuff they had this
great big huge Seerat like a lot of
these series of events that were
designed for the purpose of basically
wrapping things up or the very least
allowing marvel to segue into stories
that would you know basically lead up to
the collapse of the multiverse original
sin was one of the most notable and the
Simpson original sin show that McPhee
had killed the watcher but in terms of
Hickman's Avengers and new Avengers it
showed that Captain America was
previously part of the Illuminati and
then basically was ousted because he
didn't agree with the idea of destroying
worlds that we're gonna crash into the
main Marvel Universe and destroy them
both and so because of that the
Illuminati kicked him out and wiped his
memory and so it created all these
really cool stories and things like that
and we'll we'll cross that bridge when
we go through our whole following Thanos
throughout the history of Marvel's
cosmology all of his stories and
everything going into the remastering of
Hickman's Avengers and new Avengers but
the fact remains here that in terms of
the age of Ultron story what that did is
it basically had Wolverine travel back
in time and then kill Hank Pym only to
travel back in time a second time and
stop himself from killing Hank Pym and
so because of the fact that the story
was in and of itself crazy in terms of
time travel what Brian Michael Bendis
and Marvel did is they said there's been
too many instances on too many occasions
in Marvel Comics when people have
traveled back in time and try to fix
things the time is not some linear
constitutive Lee a living organism and
so by virtue of Wolverine going back in
time so many times he basically broke
time itself that's a lot of times they
were thrown out there he essentially
broke time itself and so what it did is
it sent ripples it sent shockwaves
throughout the entirety of the Marvel
multiverse which set in motion a lot of
things and really hope to contribute to
the collapse of the multiverse but in
terms of this this you know getting back
into the spider-man in terms of this
future as we see it right now we don't
know exactly what it was that happened
all we know is that the conclusion of
age of Ultron had ripple effects
throughout the entire multiverse and
it's somehow affected this particular
universe now the idea here seems to be
that again you're kind of picking up
with Miguel it's really just so it just
you know Dan Slott showing us here's
what spider-man is about here's what
spider-man you know spider-man 2099 does
he's a futuristic version of spider-man
it suits a little more durable it's got
special little goodies that separate him
and and that's really the way it goes in
the realm of the spider-man landscape
whether it's Miles Morales in the
Ultimate Universe whether it is you know
Peter Parker with the iron spider armor
or whether it's Miguel O'Hara whether
it's Kane you know bill or I'm sorry I
almost said Bill O'Reilly whether it's
Ben Reilly whatever the case may be
it's basically just all these different
versions of spider-man have something
that makes them different something that
make them a little unique they're sued
so their powers or so on and so forth
and so because of this what ended up
happening here is of course Miguel's
basically just kind of saving the day
but the reason why is because of the
fact that again this age of Ultron rip
Levin has basically caused a massive
catastrophe in the city in terms of the
timestream being all screwed out now a
lot of this is stemming from alchemax
itself alchemax being the mega
corporation that basically runs the show
it's almost like a futuristic version of
Roxxon oil or something like that the
main Marvel Universe work Rockstone is
extremely corrupt organization that has
us hands and all different kinds of
politics and behind the scenes some very
shady things assassinations of public
officials different things like that
alchemax it's very much like that in the
future but it's one of these things
where it kind of represents the
corrupted nature of corporations and
capitalism and so on and so forth
there's a lot of political themes that
went into the original spider-man 2099
line of stories but the fact remains
here that within the realm of alchemax
Oz Tyler stone is really kind of the guy
running the whole situation but Tyler
stone is the son of Tiberius stone and
in fact Miguel O'Hara himself is the son
of Tyler stone and so because of this
Miguel O'Hara and his father are really
in a kind of a battle like this eternal
battle of good and evil so to speak in
the sense that they fight each other but
what makes a situation a little more
dynamic is it would be like if Bruce
Wayne became Batman and Thomas Wayne his
father became the Joker like they're
just kind of at odds against one another
and they will be until the end of time
the issue here is that because of the
actions of Wolverine during age of
Ultron something in the past was screwed
up something in the past went wrong and
so the idea is that Tyler Stone's
effectively disappearing from the
timestream now what's really cool about
this is the way that Dan Slott does it
under no circumstances when we think of
the grandfather paradox which is to say
if you went back in time and you met
your grandfather is a child and
accidentally killed him then you would
cease to exist traditionally we just
have you just kind of break down on an
onion on the atomic level you simply
just phase out of existence because you
couldn't exist in the first place if
your grandfather was killed but the
reason why it's called a grandfather
paradox is if your grandfather died
before you could be born then how could
you have gone back in time in the first
place so again it creates all kinds of
weird situations but the way Dan Slott
does it here is it basically gives us a
chance it basically gives them it gives
them time to correct the problem in a
sense but instead of Tyler stone just
vanishing out of thin air
Tyler stones basically just sort of
disappearing and so what it tells us is
that in the past there's a sequence of
events there's you know the first event
then the second event then the third
event and we're probably on the second
at the moment which means that the the
closer these events get to the point
where Leo Tiberius stone that the father
of Tyler stone vanishes then the closer
we get to Tyler stone disappearing in
his entirety and so because of this
Miguel's basically tasked with the idea
of saving the father of Tyler stone now
the reason why this is interesting is
because on the surface Miguel's like
look you're my mortal enemy
like there's no reason for me to save
you if you die the world will be a
better place will the issue with this is
then we start invoking hypothetical
scenarios you're not pathetical
possibilities the world exists as it
does now in you know the 2099 universe
because a series of events took place
that led it to where it is whether or
not is a huge event whether or not is
the smaller than Tyler Stone was born if
Tyler son was never born what would the
world look like if alchemax never he
never came to power it might be better
it could be worse and so because of this
because of the fact that there's no
telling what the future may be mama may
hold we end up actually finding out that
that Miguel's traveling into the past is
guaranteed and the reason why is because
they show an image of him in the past
and so this basically means that he's
going to jump back into the year 2013
and try to figure out what happened that
set all these events in motion in the
first place now what we end up doing is
we actually jump back to you know again
Peter Parker superior spider-man it is
really kind of a cool moment here in
this and he's playing baseball and he
smashes the ball out of the park and
that's kind of what were you would
expect right like like Peter Parker
playing baseball like I'd never played
baseball against Peter Parker like I
don't care how fast you can throw the
ball he's going to smash it and then
everybody's you know everybody's fun is
gonna be ruined and so because of that
because we don't like people ruining
other people's fun I would not play
against Peter Parker but the cool thing
here is that this entire situation is
being monitored by Tiberius stone so
again we're back here in the present
with a father of Tyler stone
Tiberius himself and so because that's
what this really means is that high
Beria's is basically engineering the
fall of you know really of horizon labs
and I remember horizon laughs is the
organization that's basically founded by
Maximo Dell
it's a giant think tank it's designed to
basically grab some of the bright young
members of society and have them create
inventions and different things like
that that will make society better it's
very similar to like Hickman's future
foundation under Reed Richards and the
spa
for the course right I mean in Marvel
Comics its but you know even in DC
comics you don't have like one
organization that represents one thing
like you don't have like one
government-sanctioned superhero team you
don't have one you know think tank all
different kinds of people have different
kinds of think tanks Reed Richards has a
Future Foundation which is some of the
world's smartest kids that he's allowed
in there Maximo Dell has horizon labs
will see Parker Industries begin to take
form over the course of this story you
see a lot of different organizations and
groups that serve the same purpose you
know but they're basically just led by
different people now it doesn't mean
they're at odds it's not like Maximo
Dell was like I hate Reed Richards in
his future foundation you know I'm gonna
get those evil curves I mean it's
nothing like that you know there's the
thing is it's silly and sinister is that
but it just serves the purpose of kind
of reminding us there's a much bigger
world and in the realm of corporations
and companies and so on and so forth but
the reason why why Tiberius stone is so
significant here is because of the fact
that what Tiberius stone has been doing
or at least what he's done is he's
basically set the stage for horizon labs
to essentially go under for maximum Dell
himself to be arrested due to the fact
that the the different experiments that
he's been working on I have basically
come into into light as being illegal in
the sense of he's tampering with Todd
the sense that he basically tried to
make or at least one of the people
they're trying to make a knockoff of
vibranium and ultimately screwed it up
treated reverb iam instead different
things like that now max Modell wasn't
the one who invented these things but
it's a classic example that if you're at
work and you screw up if somebody higher
than your boss sees it it makes your
boss look bad because your boss is in
charge of you and so because of that max
Modell is basically the one taking the
fall here because he's the one who's in
charge of horizon labs he's responsible
for all the different experiments that
his employees are working on at the
moment now at this point we're basically
kind of reminded by Dan Slott that
goblin nation is still going on which is
to say Norman Osborn is still making his
own green goblin army this is a wildly
significant here it's just kind of a
little small reminder but it's Dan Slott
basically saying you know keep in the
back of your head guys Norman Osborn the
Green Goblin basically found a link to
hack into a superior spider-man's little
spider BOTS in order to keep all the
goblins in New York hidden away from
those spots they won't know the goblins
are there they won't detect them and
they won't report back and so because of
that it's basically Dan Slott reminding
us that superior spider-man is
completely unaware of the fact that
Green Goblin is building an army for
himself within the city of New York now
at this point we transition over to
alkanes and alkenes basically just the
the
predecessor to Alchemist but the idea
here is that outcome has basically taken
over horizon labs or is it really kind
of initiating a you know a hostile
takeover now this is basically short for
Alan chemical but because of the fact
that the head of horizon labs Maximo
Dell is being taken away essentially
what happened here is is again by nature
of it being a hostile takeover Alan
chemical has bought controlling stake in
in horizon labs and that's why it's
considered to be a hostile takeover
because basically when you have publicly
traded companies the people who have a
majority share a majority hold in the
company have a lot more authority than
those who don't
with with Alan chemical holding the
majority shares of horizon labs this now
means that Alan chemical owns horizon
labs is up they can dissolve the company
they can absorb the company they can do
any number of things that they want now
of course superior spider-man is very
much aware that Tiberius stone seems to
have a hand in this as as most everybody
else just because of the fact that
Tiberius is on with Alan chemical and
it's like hey look guys we'll keep you
around
you know if we're interested in if we
choose to but it's really superior
spider-man kind of chasing him down with
the intention of tracking these guys
down now at this point we actually pick
up with Grady remember great he's one of
the members of horizon labs and Grady
basically came to the idea that in his
mind Tiberius Starling had set in motion
these events was just to say he believes
the site Tiberius stone had sabotage
these different experiments which is the
reason why they had gone awry and it's
the reason for why Mac's Modell's being
arrested in the first place so the
intention of Grady is to travel back in
time and is simply witness what it is
that the Tiberius Stone is doing now
this is the inherent difference between
what it is a Dan slots doing in this
story and what we would see in
traditional time-travel stories and
traditional stories where time-travel is
invoked time travel in and of itself is
just a way out it's a way for a rider to
get themselves out of a hole they buy
this incredibly amazing story and it's
super super good but they don't know how
to end it well then suddenly here comes
Doctor Strange and Doctor Strange wished
them away to the future and then
everything is okay it's one of those
things that fans absolutely hate because
it's a lazy way to end a story what Dan
Slott does here is he doesn't use time
travel to end a story he uses time
travel to further a story and that's
where fans don't really have any problem
with it you know if that's like hey look
if it's a means to an end which is to
say it's a tool to be used in order to
give us an organic ending to a story
then that's fine then that works and so
what ends up happening here is as Grady
basically just kind of jumps back and
starts looking through different points
now before Grady can actually end
for this device Miguel O'Hara suddenly
jumps through and again this really kind
of feeds into the idea of Miguel being
here in the sense that you know the guys
that alchemax in here in the year 2099
sent him through this portal because it
was a two-way street it was gonna be
opened up it was basically Grady opening
the door and then they knew at least at
alchemax they knew this door will be
open at this particular time and it
would allow Miguel to jump through and
so because of this Miguel's basically a
man on a mission his idea is trying to
figure out what it is that's taking
place that's leading to the death of
Tyler stone in the year 2099 Wyatt is a
Tyler stone is disappearing from
existence and so with superior
spider-man catching up to tonight
Tiberius stone and the intention of
killing him the funny thing here is that
Tiberius is like well you know you can't
harm me I mean you know you're
spider-man you don't kill people I'm
following within the confines of the law
what I'm doing is legal yeah it's really
crummy and yeah it's really shady but
you can't hurt me right and this really
kind of goes back to the discussion that
we had about injustice you know free
will gives people the freedom to do
anything they want to but it also gives
them the freedom to deal with the
consequences the consequences may not be
legal the consequences may just be that
you pissed somebody off really bad and
they're gonna kill you that's the
consequence of the things that you said
and the things that you did that's
what's going on here with Tiberius
he basically pissed off superior
spider-man by screwing him over and
screwing over the entirety of horizon
labs now the other half of this is as
Dan Slott furthering this idea that
Doctor Octopus and the body of Peter
Parker is becoming a good guy because
under normal circumstances we wouldn't
have seen Doctor Octopus do this Doctor
Octopus would have been like well I mean
you know look at the look at the entire
situation get a lay of the land and if
it's if it works in my benefit I'll let
it happen if it doesn't then I'll stop
it but then I'll try to find some way to
make sure that I come out on top here
superior spider-man is being altruistic
in this situation what Tiberius Stone is
doing is wrong horizon labs is a great
organization max Modell is a legit guy
superior spider-man is basically going
to try to kill Tiberius stone because
he's a dick he doesn't deserve to live
and horizon Labs is going to continue on
exonerated of the crimes that has been
falsely accused of so that's kind of the
cool thing here is this this is
altruistic spider-man now the funny
thing about this too is that Doc Ock has
never met spider-man 2099
he doesn't know who Miguel O'Hara is and
this is Dan Slott kind of harkening back
to the death quote-unquote of Peter
Parker when superior spider-man
basically purged all of
Parker's legitimate memories from his
mind the issue here is that when Miguel
O'Hara first shows up Peter Parker's met
Miguel before they they've been a team
they teamed up on a multitude of
occasions Miguel knows who's spider-man
is he knows spider-man is Peter Parker
but Doctor Octopus doesn't know this and
so in his mind this is just a guy who
looks like spider-man he doesn't know
where he's from he doesn't know what
he's about and so Miguel kind of
initially greets him as a friend
superior spider-man greets him as an
enemy and so what this does is lead to a
fight between the two now in terms of
Miguel he's basically trying to solve
this problem he's trying to figure out
what's going on and so in a lot of ways
and what he's doing here is he's looking
at superior looking at spider-man and
saying I don't know what happened to you
I don't know what's been done to you but
you've become more extreme and if I have
to put you down in order to preserve the
future that's exactly what I'll do now
at this point we also have Tyler stone
in the future communicating with you
know Miguel O'Hara and this is when
Tyler basically says hey look you know
that Spiderman referenced that guy is
Tiberius stone that's my father and so
if he dies I will cease to exist that's
the issue here Tiberius stone somewhere
along the line was killed and so because
of the fact that he was killed my entire
existence is coming to an end as will
yours and so again this is Dan Slott
kind of meddling around with time a
little bit kind of messing with time
itself but again it still kind of works
at this point Miguel O'Hara's role is
solidified we now know exactly what it
is that he's doing here his job is to
preserve the life of Tiberius
Stumpf the reason why this matters is
because of the fact that there is a
segment and there will be a section
coming up when Miguel doesn't know if he
should he's like maybe I should just
sacrifice my life and make the future
better you know I'll let Tiberius stone
die or I'll kill him myself
Tyler stone will cease to exist and then
I will cease to exist but at the end of
the day it'll all still work out because
the future will be a better place or at
least I hope it will be and so in the
midst of all this we pick up with with
Grady and again Grady jumping through
here you know kind of going back in time
it's not wildly significant all it
really does is just confirm the fact
that Tiberius stone was messing around
and sabotaging these different
experiments that had gone wrong and at
Horizon labs it so we don't really need
to go super in-depth into that I mean
that's really the extent of what we
would be what we would be discussing
anyway I think how do the main focus
here should be on Miguel and in superior
spider-man and so the conflict the
battle between the two of them is
actually really interesting is actually
really cool in the sense that they're
both relatively evenly matched
smarter match 199 has tech at his
disposal and that's one of the
differences here but that's also
something that dance lots kind of
harkening on because of the fact that
Doctor Octopus took over the body of
Peter Parker and Miguel O'Hara's future
superior spider-man is a part of the
spider-man mythos it'll be chalked up to
the idea that Spiderman became really
really extreme for a little while but
the different tools that Doc Ock used in
terms of his time as spider-man his
enhancements to the suit all of that
falls into the different studies that
Miguel O'Hara has done on spider-man if
so whether Miguel O'Hara knows it or not
his role as spider-man 29 is influenced
by the things that Doc Ock has done ask
superior spider-man and so again it's
really kind of interesting to sort of
see them a meet and to see how one
influences the other but with Tiberius
stone having the ability to basically
disrupt spider-man's spider-sense of
course what this does is it allows
Miguel O'Hara to take off with Tiberius
stone and of course you know following
this it's basically superior spider-man
trying to track him down and trying to
figure out what's going on now this is
the segment when Miguel begins to
question whether or not he's doing the
right thing he sits down and he
basically says look you know if I let
Tiberius stone die then that means that
he'll never have Tyler stone which means
Tyler stone will never have me I'll
cease to exist but alchemax will never
become what it is
Tiberius stone will not be able to lay
the groundwork for alchemax Tyler stone
will never be able to build on that
groundwork and the world will not be as
crappy as it is but the funny thing
about this is that Miguel O'Hare is not
taking into account the realm of
possibilities you know in a in a free
market system if Microsoft fails
somebody will take their place if Apple
fails somebody will take their place God
willing Ubisoft fails somebody will take
their place because of this what this
means is that you know Miguel O'Hara
could very well be trading one devil for
another and in this situation the devil
you know is better than the devil you
don't and so because of this he could be
making a much worse future and that's
something that he contemplates he says
look I don't know what the future would
be like if I cease to exist if alchemax
cease to exist who knows how the future
could turn out I mean who knows if
alchemax could basically restruck be
restructured a hundred years from now
and it leads earth India this utopian
era and if I if I kill Tiberius stone
that utopia era never comes into
existence because people never see
alchemax they never come to the
conclusion we need something better than
that we could have a better society for
ourselves he's like I can make things
worse
in the long run and so because that he
ultimately says look I have to let him
live and so with this in mind Tiberius
son kind of has you know upper hand he
has the upper hand here because of the
fact that he jumps off the building he's
like I guarantee you're gonna save me so
he jumps off the building spider-man
2099 saves his life and so it's almost
guarantee that his future is set in
stone and so because of this with this
story intending to lead into
spider-verse
and with the really the superior
spider-man run designed to sort of wrap
things up and bring things winding down
what is up happening here is superior
spider-man it eventually catches up with
with Miguel O'Hara now the funny thing
here this is actually kind of a
hilarious moment Miguel realizing what
it is that's going on realizing that all
of reality is basically at the threat of
destruction simply because of the fact
that one of the experiments Tiberius
Tony messed with was an experiment
dealing with time which in turn would
basically lead to the destruction of all
thing because all the energy being
emitted by this time-travel device can't
be contained
Miguel O'Hara shows up on the scene with
Tiberius stone it says look guys
everything's beginning to go awry
everything's beginning to go insane the
only way for us to fix this is to follow
my lead and the reason why is because
you know Miguel O'Hara is like look I
come from a future where this happened
and I know that what you guys are going
to try to do is fail but I know the way
to fix this problem and so the issue
here is that while he's on the verge
once he once he says look you know all
we have to do is this thing superior
spider-man shows about a nowhere and
knocks him out and this is a funny
moment because then everybody just like
dude what did you do we're like we're
like 15 minutes away from the
destruction of the world in the universe
itself why did you knock out the one guy
who could save us now the reason why I
say this leads into spider-verse is
because of the fact that with Miguel
O'Hara knocked out it now falls on to
superior spider-man to take to take the
lead here the issue is that again with
him wiping the memories of Peter Parker
he doesn't know how to solve this
problem and the reason why is because of
the fact that when the original
vibranium experiment by so Johny Joffrey
one arrived and Peter Parker as his
normal self basically began manipulating
energy in order to contain the energy
that was let off contained the explosion
and the destruction of horizon labs a
superior spider-man purged that memory
and so he doesn't know what Peter Parker
did in order to keep that a massive
amount of energy from totally collapsing
in on itself and that's what this is
this is basically a much larger version
of the energy let off by so Johnny
Geoffrey's attempts to make vibranium
remember we had talked about how you
know at least during that story we
talked about how Doctor Doom invading
Wakanda
basically taking vibranium had led to
black panther rendering all vibranium
across the world inert which in turn led
to Sozzani Joffrey trying to make
artificial vibranium it had all sort of
led up to this moment when Peter
Parker's intelligence was being
demonstrated now superior spider-man
doesn't Dunn doesn't know what to do and
so he's basically on the verge of being
seen as a complete and total fraud he's
on the verge of being seen into God as a
guy who doesn't know what he's doing
who's basically making things up along
the way and so because of this with this
massive time device on the verge are
completely and totally you know
obliterating everything what happens is
superior spider-man tells everybody to
leave he starts meddling with the device
to trying to find a way to fix it and
then the entirety of horizon labs just
vanishes up and thin it totally
disappears now because of the fact that
Tiberius stone was saved by Miguel
O'Hara what this means is that Tiberius
stone is now safe or I guess it means
that that Tyler stone in the future is
is still alive and the future is
guaranteed now this was the moment that
Tyler stone was talking about in this
moment right now things went a different
way we don't know exactly what way
things had normally gone in but what
seems to have been the case is that in
this scenario a superior spider-man at
some point along the line did not tell
them to leave and so the result was that
they were all basically yankton through
the timestream and Tiberius Stone was
presumably killed somewhere they all
during that time frame and it led to the
destruction of everything or it led to
the death of Tyler stone of the presumed
you know death of Tyler stone which
would have led to this led to the death
of Miguel O'Hara hence the entire
situation
why Miguel is here in the first place
but in this moment when superior
spider-man basically vanishes and in the
moment that he reappears on the street
the entirety of spider-verse took place
that being said we are going to discuss
the whole spider-verse event the issue
here is that with the whole spider-verse
event it's not an easy thing to sort out
there's actually a lot of lead-up in
terms of like more LAN and in terms of
Ezekiel and the other storyline and you
know the Clone Saga and all different
kinds of kind of thing there's there's
all kinds of stuff that goes on there
but the fact remains here that again Dan
Slott sort of wrapping things up
bringing things to a close and one of
the things that he wraps up pretty fast
is the idea of Mary Jane Watson Mary
Jane Watson had been trying to get ahold
of superior spider-man this entire time
and he was basically getting annoyed
with her saying look she needs to move
on like she needs to get her life
together she needs to move on get
another guy she's hung up on me
it's it's a problem well of course when
she when he finally calls her back she
basically says look I've been
up on you it's time for me to move on I
have no romantic interest in you anymore
this'll is basically Dan Slott saying
hey look these two guys are never going
to get together these two guys are never
going to be anything significant to one
another now from this point going
forward what this does is it basically
picks up with the aftermath of
spider-verse and it picks up with
superior spider-man ramping things up
extremely fast to basically make a
better life for Peter Parker that's kind
of the funny thing here at the same time
it's also him trying to make sure that
he stays superior spider-man and we'll
cross that bridge once we get to it with
a spider-verse line of stories but from
this point what we're gonna do is were
actually gonna stop superior spider-man
and we're gonna jump back and we're
gonna start covering the superior I
guess the spider more stuff so we're
gonna jump back to some of the older
stories of amazing spider-man and then
pickup into into spider-verse hopefully
that way we have everything covered in
order to make it all make sense and then
once spider-verse is done we'll jump
back here to superior spider-man it's
the best way I know how to do it in
order to make sure that we fall into the
chronology of the amazing spider-man
because that's what all this is I mean
this is all designed for the purpose so
that when the spider-man movie comes out
and people are searching for spider-man
content everywhere they can pick up with
these videos and chronologically go
through everything about the spider-man
mythology and learn everything there is
to learn in terms of dance lots run with
big time going forward going into
all-new all-different marvel so earlier
today I was reading a Silver Surfer
against the tide and I really want to
cover Hickman's like Avengers New
Avengers infinity all that stuff like
right now those of you guys remember
that really old Silver Surfer video that
idea that had that amazing monologue
that was from the opening part of
against the tide like the first 20 pages
or something like that it's one of those
Marvel infinite comics so it's it's like
80 pages long but technically in terms
of like it being a complete comic it's
only like 20-something pages long but
it's designed for digital release and
it's designed to be read on tablets and
stuff like that so you know it makes it
a little more interesting in terms of
how it all works is actually really cool
when you go through and start reading
them on tablets either they're really
really interesting but the fact remains
here that we will not get the Hickman's
Avengers of New Avengers or anything
like that until we do the Thanos stuff
and that comes after Thor which comes
after this superior spider-man so in the
previous video I had mentioned that we
were gonna stop superior spider-man and
we were gonna jump into spider-verse but
really two videos away from finishing
superior spider-man so it doesn't really
make any sense to kind of stop and then
come
can make two videos instead what we'll
do is we'll cover spider-verse
and what does kind of jump back to
spider-verse in the beginning and just
say all this takes place between like
everything that we talked about from
like you know X video from like that
video up until the end of spider-verse
all takes place at this point between
superior spider-man and we'll just call
it a day I think that'll be pretty it'll
be a lot easier to follow that way then
it will be you know any other way in
terms of you know doing anything kind of
crazy but the fact remains here that
with this particular video we're gonna
be basically getting superior venom
we're gonna be getting superior
spider-man with the Venom symbiote and
it actually works out pretty well it's a
really interesting interesting concept
but what Dan Slott does here is he
actually rolls over agent venom into
this whole thing now when we talked
about Lee price venom from Marvel now
2.0 we had talked about how that was
basically the evolution really the end
of the Venom symbiote run in terms of
giving the Venom's to be a character and
giving it evolution and kind of evolving
it over the course of marvel's
publication history it's what really
made sense but what this is gonna show
us is the idea that that flash Thompson
believes but he understands the symbian
so it's kind of the early days of
growing it and evolving it and showing
us that it actually does have sentience
and where it goes and and that kind of a
thing so it's pretty cool but again this
little bit of a segment with with agent
venom is pretty short it's really just
Dan Slott saying hey look it's only a
couple pages but it's really Dan Slott
saying hey look you know agent venom is
gonna be facing off against superior
spider-man so that was kind of the cool
thing because the further we got into
this the more it was like him fighting
different people so it'll be like in
this video it'll be superior spider-man
vs. agent venom and then superior venom
versus the avengers so it's kind of cool
it's interesting in terms of them
fighting one another but at this point
we jump over to superior spider-man
proper and we basically join him with
the unveiling of Parker Industries now
again this is the early days of Parker
industries before it becomes the major
conglomerate that it is right now and
all-new all-different marvel so we have
people like said Johnny joffrey who have
been brought on board Anna Marconi who's
been brought on board now of course Aunt
May and Jay jonah Jameson senior are
basically the silent investors they're
the ones that were kind of throwing
money towards Peter Parker and letting
him be a part of it all but at the same
time we also have like cardiac
you know elias worth and being part of
the whole parker industries team of
course cardiac basically being a guy who
is more or less a vigilante but was
doing it for the purpose of helping
people basically stealing medical
equipment things like that in order to
provide healthcare for people who'd
assembly couldn't afford it
their own so again it's really cool to
see these little bits and pieces begin
to come together and these little these
little bobs and bits sort of you know
create a more cohesive story from the
stuff that we've all ran over so far
even going as far back as spider-man big
Tom and of course that's really why I
was necessary because it's all with just
one gigantic story and even once we
progress we get into all-new
all-different marvel when we cover
spider-verse different things like that
it'll all just continue to be one part
of a major cohesive story so again with
the idea of Anna Marconi one of the
greatest things about this is that Dan
Slott was basically using her as a way
to essentially turn superior spider-man
around and make him a good guy to give
him a reason to be a good guy now again
it's also Doc Ock so Doc Ock is still
somewhat nefarious and he's still
willing to commit murder but at the end
of the day it's all basically a case of
the ends justifying the means which he's
not entirely wrong about I think he's a
little heavy-handed in terms of how he
deals with criminals but the fact
remains if you kill a guy for committing
a crime he won't repeat that crime
because he's dead so again it's kind of
interesting in terms of cleaning up the
streets of New York and keeping things
pretty straightforward but again um this
also basically coincides with the
arrival of a superior spider-man facing
off against agent venom and the reason
why is because of the return of a
villain named crime master now this is
not the original crime master and in
fact this is basically just a nobody but
crime master is an alias that has
previously been used and what we are
gonna find out here is that this is all
basically being done by a guy named
Roderick Kingsley now we'll get to him
here in a little bit but for right now
the fight between superior spider-man
and agent venom is actually pretty cool
just because of the fact that they're
familiar with one another or at least
agent Venom's familiar with with with
spider-man in terms of the hero and
Peter Parker the problem is that this is
not Peter Parker and again that's one of
the crazy things is because people who
have known Peter or people who have
known spider-man are used to him you
know acting a certain way but here he's
murderous and he shows the idea but he's
going to kill agent venom with fire you
know and destroy the Venom symbiote in
the process now again this is also Dan
Slott basically building on the whole
lot agent venom concept in the sense
that that Flash Thompson knows the venom
Samiha or believes he understands the
Venom's to be at better than anybody
else now in terms of it actually talking
to people that's not really happening
yet instead it's more or less flash
talking to the Venom symbiote and
keeping it under control so again it's
all really just kind of growing it and
evolving it and so on and so forth but
it's also this idea that the Venom
symbiote will
whatever needs to do to keep itself
alive it will avoid weaknesses different
things like that so of course well the
conflict is pretty short-lived if the
reason for this is because of the fact
that basically agent venom Flash
Thompson bolts out and then uses the
Venom symbiote to essentially
shape-shift and keep anybody from being
able to realize who he is or what's
going on so at this point we sort of
jump over to carly cooper now remember
carly cooper is the ex-girlfriend of
peter parker and knows that he's
spider-man this is the revelation that
was basically given to us by Dan Slott
following the Spider Island event
because of the fact that Manhattan saw
all these different people getting
smarter Man abilities but Peter Parker
was the only one who was familiar with
them just going through and using a
modicum of intelligence a carly cooper
basically deduced the fact that Peter
Parker was spider-man and so because of
this with with spider-man acting a Riley
spider-man acting so starkly different
Carly Cooper's initial idea was that's
not Peter Parker somebody did something
to him and is either mind controlling
him or somehow took over his body and so
in the background of everything that's
been going on
Carly Cooper's basically been
investigating and trying to figure out
who it is that's actually in control of
Peter Parker now where she's basically
stumbled across information that all but
guarantees that Doctor Octopus is the
one that's pulling the strings here that
Doc Ock has taken over the body of Peter
she doesn't really know how deep things
go she just simply knows the Doc Ock is
somehow involved in this but in the
midst of her investigations she's
basically captured by the green Goblin's
people but the fact remains that she's
brought before the Green Goblin
and his question is who is spider-man I
want to know spider-man's real identity
now of course Carly is just not willing
to get that information out it's really
one of those things where she's like
I'll take it to the grave I'll die
before I tell you it really kind of
makes sense but again a lot of this sort
of goes back and forth between you know
between Flash Thompson and I'm sorry
between a superior spider-man and agent
venom now keep in mind here Flash
Thompson does not have the use of his
legs the Venom symbiote is basically the
one thing that allows him to be able to
walk and so because of that the venom
some it really has to sort of exhaust
itself you know we're exhaust its
abilities more so than it normally would
if it were like Peter Parker or somebody
like that who could walk around on his
own but the fact remains here that in
the eyes of Flash Thompson because of
the fact that spider-man is acting so
completely different than what he's used
to the question is what's going on here
of course is real just kind of looking
and investigating and see if he can't
figure it out
his own now at the same time while all
this is going on Miguel
O'Hara is still around you know
spider-man 2099 is still there now of
course he's operating under the guise of
Michael O'Hara and basically pretending
to be just a member of Al Kim more or
less speaking to J John Jameson and so
on and so forth he's just kind of
keeping an eye on things and doing what
he can to make sure that al Kim does not
become alchemax in the year 2099 but
again it's just kind of Dan Slott
showing us where we were realize the
moment where things are sort of sitting
and how it all comes together but in the
midst of Flash Thompson basically
receiving a treatment from cardiac from
Elias wertham in terms of giving him
artificial real prosthetics providing
him with artificial legs and superior
spider-man shows up for the purpose of
intending to interrogate Flash Thompson
however the reason why is because of the
fact that from the perspective of
superior spider-man all he sees is venom
because remember Doc Ock basically
purged the memories of Peter Parker so
he does not recall anything about Flash
Thompson agent venom knowing who he is
knowing he's a good guy
it's just in his mind the Venom symbiote
is bad and the Venom's to be it has to
be taken out along with whoever it is
that's wielding it and so because of
that and using Sonic's superior
spider-man strips Flash Thompson of the
venom simian now again this is basically
kind of harkening to the idea that flash
had it under control the flash
understands the symbian the flash was
able to bond with it in a way that no
one else can or no one else ever has and
that's one of the reasons why a lot of
people really really love the idea of
agent venom because they look at Eddie
Brock and they say okay look the Venom
symbiote and Eddie Brock go together
really really well but it was only
because of the fact that they shared a
mutual hatred for Peter Parker in terms
of a beyond the surface I genuinely
understand the Venom symbiote you know
more or less concept that's Flash
Thompson and people loved that about
Flash Thompson giving the Venom symbiote
character getting it Drive giving it
ambition giving flash basically a larger
role in the Marvel Universe outside of
just the guy who was a dick to Peter
Parker when he was younger and the guy
who lost his legs and and you know in a
wartime conflict and so because of that
the Venom symbiote basically bonds
itself directly to spider-man now again
because of the fact that we know we
really don't have the Venom symbiote
speaking because it's not really talking
to people all really seems to happen
here is a Venom symbiote recognized as
spider-man that says that's the guy that
I originally wanted to be with and
that's the guy that I can be with again
so we basically sort of have a superior
venom or a superior venom here and it's
actually kind of cool in terms of how he
looks because it's basically the mind of
dr. octopus combined with the powers of
the Venom symbiote now the funny thing
about this is that Dan Slott goes all
the way back to the post um you know
1984 Secret Wars spider-man landscape
and this density basically says hey look
you know spider-man as we knew him then
when he became a host for the venom
Simeon was corrupted by he corrupted the
Venom symbiote the symbiote corrupt uh
corrupted him they basically became bad
guys to a degree now it wasn't a
traditional bad guy spider-man didn't go
around you know robbing banks or
anything like that but in terms of him
in relation to the hero that we
traditionally knew they were starkly
different it was night and day and so
that seems to be what's really happening
here superior spider-man is basically
running amuck with his new abilities
with it with a Venom symbiote being
attached to him and it was really kind
of cool to see this unfold because we
end up seeing him taking a really kind
of cutting a swath through the superhero
community more so than he had before
because now he has a new host of
abilities at his disposal and it's
really Dan Slott kind of showing us
we're kind of juxtaposing the abilities
of spider-man with the abilities of
venom but then turning around and taking
the entire concept and Paterna on his
head when he asked the question what
happens when Doctor Octopus is mined in
the body of Peter Parker gets the Venom
symbiote then what happens how crazy are
things going to get how is he going to
use the abilities is it possible you
know is it one of those things where
Doctor Octopus can overcome the Venom
symbiote or will he be corrupted with
power just like everybody else and the
answer here is that he's just like
everybody else who be corrupted by his
power he'll run amuck with these new
abilities that he has at his disposal
now in terms of our little section about
crime master earlier in this video and
Roderick Kingsley what we end up finding
out is that with Roderick Kingsley
operating as the original Hobgoblin and
more or less having been defeated on a
multitude of occasions Roderick Angley
basically came to the realization that
he could in a sense or he could really
just kind of grab a lot of these d-list
level villains either villains that were
small-time and died or villains that
were small-time and walked away could
grab their villainous identities and
then use them and essentially sell them
off and that's what he's been doing of
course we know that that Ben Urich son
basically became you know the the new
Hobgoblin you know Phil you're kind of
maintained that world for a while before
he joined the Green Goblin we
essentially have all these guys crime
master being another example it's just
small-time villains that would never
have received any attention before
getting attention here now in truth this
is a genius way to reintroduce
small-time
it's not Dan Slott saying hey look guys
like aren't you excited for the return
of crime master none at all we're not
gonna see crime master return and play
any measure of a significant role but
we're gonna see something kind of
interesting in terms of the fact that we
see these various identities showing up
these villains being used by Roderick
Angley for his own ends and then facing
off against spider-man and in different
you know different scenarios and
different situations now jumping back to
superior spider-man again because of the
fact that he's much where Peter Parker
was host in 1984 Secret Wars he's
basically brash he's arrogant you know
more so than he was before he's prone to
lash out he follows this exact same
pattern of behavior that Peter Parker
follows now what's interesting about
this is Mary Jane Watson does not
initially pick up on this it's just that
in her mind she's like what's going on
with you why are you acting so violent
why are you being this way now of course
once the Venom symbiote makes his
presence known then immediately she's
like oh my god it's the same thing all
over again the Venom symbiote taking
control of Peter Parker now in terms of
how she deals with this it's really just
kind of like okay stay out of the way
just because Mary Jane Watson is not at
a point in any former fashion where she
could take it on not to mention this
shock of seeing the Venom symbiote again
is startling to her and of course Dan
Slott is gonna use this as a way to
basically segue things back into a state
of normalcy but because of the actions
of Peter Parker because of the things
that he's done because Mary Jane Watson
looks at him that's kind of beyond the
ability to you know to return to any
measure of normalcy at least in terms of
what she's familiar with she essentially
calls in the Avengers now this is
actually a really cool situation we
don't really see like a daredevil
hanging out and just be like oh man I'm
in over my head
I'm gonna call the Avengers a Sal over a
comic pop actually made a really had a
really really good discussion wasn't and
I can't reference the comic and he can
remember it either but it was a really
cool moment I think it was bull's eye
but it was an instance where daredevil
had basically taken out bull's eye and
the Avengers showed up and said no he's
coming with us
and they just took bull's eye away from
daredevil but we usually see The
Avengers intervening only in times of
like a huge situation or whenever it's
convenient for this particular scenario
the Avengers are called by Mary Jane
Watson because she's like look the Venom
symbiote return to spider-man now in
terms of what this means for the
spider-man landscape this is Dan Slott
showing us how dangerous the Venom
symbiote is which is something that we
knew about but for the modern spider-man
reader
picking up after
they didn't know this they read about it
you know a time or two or maybe they'd
heard people speaking about it they knew
about it through word of mouth but in
terms of witnessing it with their own
eyes they didn't really know off the top
of her heads now this is basically the
New Avengers Iron Man Thor Captain
America Wolverine and so on these are
the New Avengers essentially coming
together for the purpose of trying to
take out the Venom symbiote but the
funny thing is that this is the Venom
symbiote with the mind of Doctor Octopus
in the body of Peter Parker and it
crushes the Avengers now the funny thing
about this is that it's not like
superior venom has inside knowledge
because Robert Doctor Octopus wiped his
mind of Peter Parker and so because of
that with Peter Parker seemingly being
purged there's nothing here to indicate
that superior venom has an upper hand on
the Avengers instead the indication here
seems to be that he's just that damn
powerful that he's just that capable
he's just that wildly durable in terms
of his strength his agility the
different abilities that he can extend
you know beyond himself in order to take
out the Avengers so he's literally it's
a one-man army superior venom is able to
hold his own against Wolverine Captain
America Black Widow Thor and
spider-woman
all at the same time and that is an
incredible feat in and of itself so it's
just kind of cool to see but in the
midst of all this Tony Stark of course
be the man behind all this basically ask
the question do we know if that slash
Thompson losing his mind or is it
legitimately spider-man now of course in
order to get an answer to this they
basically run over to Parker industries
and Tony Stark meets Flash Thompson and
this is when he realizes that is
genuinely spider-man so of course the
question now becomes what happened why
is it the flash Thompson is you know
temporarily lost the Venom symbiote what
in the world is going on here so again
this is basically Dan Slott kind of
setting the seed setting the stage for
what will become the bigger picture in
terms of superior spider-man in relation
to the Venom symbiote and the fallout of
all this when superior spider-man
finally comes to an end and so again you
know with this battle against the
Avengers wrapping up relatively fast we
basically have Flash Thompson using the
Iron Man suit to essentially show up
here of course Tony Stark lends it to
him to go to the battlefield see if you
can't talk some sense into the Venom
symbiote but the manifestation of the
venom simmias feelings and thoughts and
emotions begin to arise when flash
arrives on the scene and the symbiote
basically says look as agent venom you
use drugs to keep me subdued we don't
really work together organically you
know you basically keep me under control
chemicals and different things
like that and so because of this this is
the venom Samia at its most basic
essentially lashing out going crazy
attacking the various Avengers now of
course in response to this Doc Ock
basically regains himself and tries to
expel the Venom symbiote but it really
isn't able to do it on its own now again
this is a return to familiarity keep in
mind Peter wasn't able to officially and
finally cast off the Venom symbiote
until he basically encountered Reed
Richards who told him what it was Peter
began to realize what was going on with
the Venom's to be at new as only when he
was at his absolute strongest that he
was able to get rid of it with regards
to dr. a to dr. octopus he can't do it
on its own so what ends up happening
here is out of nowhere we basically end
up having Peter Parker making his return
now again this is the consciousness of
Peter and what Dan Slott basically says
is that this consciousness has basically
been hidden away from Doctor Octopus
ever since Doctor Octopus believed that
he had basically wiped it away why Peter
away from his mind so it's cool to kind
of get this return it's cool to kind of
see this great moment show up just
because of the fact that again it's Dan
Slott saying hey look guys lest we
forget Peter Parker will make his return
so it was Dan Slott kind of beginning to
wind down it's Dan Slott beginning to
sort of bring things to an end and say
okay now we're gonna go ahead and segue
into the return of Peter Parker proper
and the removal of Doctor Octopus from
controlling the body of Peter we're
gonna start moving in the direction of
wrapping up superior spider-man and so
again because of all this the venom
Samiha basically returns back to Flash
Thompson who calls it a day and Peter
Parker again more or less comments about
how Doctor Octopus still doesn't realize
that he's there and he can more or less
operate from the shadows of his own mind
so to speak and essentially stay hidden
away from everything now again because
of the fact that this leads into goblin
nation this basically leads into the war
of the goblins what we end up getting
here is this sort of begin to wind down
as things begin to wrap up relatively
fast is that we have Roderick Kingsley
more or less coming face-to-face so to
speak with the Green Goblin in the sense
they are basically communicating but
again Roderick Kingsley has basically
been building up his own army he's been
building up his own a Hobgoblin army so
to speak the various people that he's
lent his lint you know different
technologies out to but we also have the
Green Goblin who's been using the Goblin
formula as well as just pretty
underhanded tactics in order to create
an army for himself and the idea here is
we're basically gonna have these
different goblin armies going against
one another you know facing off as this
starts to wrap up the question that's
being asked here by Tony Stark
is
what's going on with spider-man now we
know previously that when a sample was
taken by the Avengers with regards you
know to Peter to analyze and see whether
or not there was anything going on if he
was like a scroll or something along
those lines they basically come to the
conclusion that nobody had done anything
to him but Tony Stark basically makes
the case it says look while we were off
in space we were off doing our own thing
we were analyzing you know we were you
know you guys were working with this and
that's fine but I'm the loose equipment
better than anybody else and when he
starts to go through it what he realizes
is that somebody had tampered with the
equipment and when the questions asked
who it was at tampered with the
equipment to skew the results of
spider-man it turned out to be
spider-man himself and so again this is
basically all the roads leading to the
idea the superior spider-man is being
tracked down by the goblins and by the
Avengers basically the world is
crumbling down around him okay so we are
we're really at the end of superior
spider-man I mean this is the last story
goblin nation but what Lee is one of the
reasons and something I'm hoping you
notice over the course of this story one
of the reasons why I wanted to do the
superior spider-man run is because what
Dan Slott did with this was either
include kind of rap in or offer some
retcons with regards to the creation of
alchemax the company that exists that's
the main enemy of Miguel O'Hara in
spider-man 2099 and so assuming that we
go forward and start doing spider-man
2099 stuff what I wanted this series to
do is serve as somewhat of like an
origin story for alchemax
so that we could just kind of jump into
spider-man 2099 and not have to go hoots
job explanations and so on and so forth
we could focus on the story itself with
you guys to be able to reference this
material with regards to where Miguel
O'Hara is coming from and how alchemax
came into existence and that's really
what a lot of this does this is really
dad's lot kind of showing us the
building of alchemax in real time now
we'll get to what alchemax is here in a
little bit for those people who were new
to the spider-man landscape because
again this is really all just kind of
giving people an idea of what spider-man
is about especially with the release of
the upcoming film as well as just kind
of passers-by who stumble across my
channel and have an interest in
spider-man but this basically coincides
with the Green Goblin Norman Osborn
making his move on New York and so
essentially what's been happening here
is he's been staging a series of
small-time skirmishes absorbing
different aspects of the criminal
underworld and this really comes out of
several different stories some of which
we need to know and
I've done and some of which we don't
really need to know and we can kind of
gloss over Oh with regards to the stuff
that we do need to know is pretty much
everything we've covered in superior
spider-man so far that Norman Osborn was
basically working behind the scenes to
make his triumphant return to conquer
New York on that carly cooper the former
girlfriend of peter parker had
discovered the Doctor Octopus had
swapped minds the Peter Parker and she
kept it all recorded in a journal but
when she was kidnapped by the Green
Goblin you know what she was turned into
a goblin using the formula she basically
handed the journal over to Norman who in
turn read it and discovered the fact
that Peter Parker Anna and Doctor
Octopus had switched bodies the other
half of this is that in his attempt to
basically streamline the role of being
spider-man a superior spider-man had
essentially distributed all these
different little spider robots around
the city of New York and on the whole
they worked it would allow him to see
everything that was going on and so if
there was a crime taking place like a
mugging or something like that he didn't
need to intervene all he had to do was
just call the cops and the cops would
respond it allowed him to be virtually
everywhere at once but if it was a
massive event if it was some great big
huge calamity that required his
attention he could leave whatever was
that he was doing and go to that
particular incident the downside to this
is that Norman Osborn effectively
grabbed one of his BOTS managed to hack
into it using kind of a subroutine and
then in turn reprogram the robots so
they would never recognize anybody with
a goblin face and so they would
basically treat them as though they
didn't exist and what it did is it
allowed Norman Osborn to execute the
second part of his plan and the second
part of his plan was to basically build
a goblin army now this was composed of
several different things the first of
which was really the role of a guy named
Roderick Kingsley Roderick Kingsley as
we talked about before was the original
Hobgoblin he was designed to be the new
goblin that Spiderman would go against
following the death of the Green Goblin
now of course that's how he was written
but the Green Goblin was just so wildly
popular Marvel had to bring him back and
so the result was that we kind of got
Hobgoblin and Green Goblin and they both
serve different roles but they were both
relatively popular in the realm of in
the realm of Marvel comics but Roderick
Kingsley having long since uh more or
less abandoned the role of the Hobgoblin
essentially sort of taking all these
different identities that belong to
small-time villains and then franchising
them out giving them to different
criminals allowing criminals to operate
as those you know under those bad guys
identities commit crimes so that
but he would know that it was actually
those criminals so for example you know
Phil uric Phil uric was operating as the
Hobgoblin for most of this story but
because of the fact that the identity of
the Hobgoblin is associated with
Roderick Kingsley Kingsley could remain
in hiding Phil Urich
could be the Hobgoblin and anybody who
knew about about the Hobgoblin would
think that it was Roderick Kingsley and
not Phil Urich and so again that's
really how a lot of these identities
these you know these villainous roles
worked themselves out at the same time
we also had the hand and that came out
of a story called a shadow land but
essentially all that really dealt with
was the idea that the hand was being
used by King Penn to basically keep his
thumb on the city of New York the issue
is that when superior Sparta man had
basically invaded the kingpins base of
operations ran him out of New York what
was left of the hand retreated to Norman
Osborn and joined his goblin army and so
that's really how a lot of these things
worked out who is really just grabbing
all these seven plot threads and just
kind of bringing them into one cohesive
story and so the result here is that we
basically pick up with Hobgoblin making
his move now this coincides with the
idea that superior spider-man is trying
to figure out how in the world it was
that Hobgoblin managed to circumvent his
programming if Hobgoblin I'm sorry if I
Green Goblin is back if Norman Osborn is
there in the city of New York and
superior spider-man's spider BOTS did
not pick up on his face then the
question is why and so this is what he
basically goes any visits a young kid by
the name of who want to Jackson now what
Jackson was a member of horizon laps and
he was actually the person who had
designed the facial recognition software
of the spider BOTS who would in turn
catalog criminals in order for superior
spider-man to use their identities later
on if they ever were to commit crimes he
would know who they were again part of
the whole streamlined process now of
course who watch who's not a bad guy
here I mean he's not a villain what we
end up finding out is that he had
basically used a database with regards
to information that was being sent out
and so on and so forth tapping into
existing databases what the Green Goblin
did was basically hijack this frequency
and then reprogrammed the facial
software so the facial software would
never see goblins who would never
identify them and it would never
basically report back that a goblin had
been spotted and so again this creates
kind of a weird situation because what
this does is it basically leads to
superior spider-man using an utter
underground tunnel system that was
formed by the Green Goblin himself to
allow his guys to move back and forth
throughout the city
without being detected - eventually
locate their base of operations now once
he gets there this presents a really
funny situation because we've never
really seen an instance this kind of
scenario before this has never taken
place and so what happens when the
number one villain of spider-man meets
the number two villain of spider-man
will they team up will they you know
become enemies Dan Slott gives us this
really cool scenario and what he
basically says is they're gonna be
enemies because keep in mind while
Doctor Octopus became spider-man you
know while he took over the body of
Peter Parker and his goal was to become
a bad guy in the moments when their
bodies are basically being swapped and
Peter realized there was no way to
regain his body back he basically
besieged Doctor Octopus ah Dragic was
experienced all the memories of Peter
and Peter said look there are people
here that I care about my Aunt May I
have a love for them different things
like that you have to keep them safe you
cannot let them be harmed and that's
really touched Doctor Octopus in the
heart of who he was and so what it ended
up doing is it basically sent him on the
path of being a good guy leading him up
to this point and so we're Green Goblin
only sees Doctor Octopus and recognises
him as one of spider-man's most notable
villains in truth Doc Ock is a good guy
now and so were the two of them kind of
going against each other it really kind
of creates a funny scenario because what
we end up finding out here is that
superior spider-man is not actually here
instead it's more of a hologram but at
the same time Norman Osborn knows how to
play this game Norman Osborn is
extremely smart and what happened is
that in the midst of this meeting Osborn
was tracing the signal of superior
spider-man back to his base of
operations on Spider Island so again
it's kind of cool because it's basically
both of them have their own methods of
their own levels of intelligence now
what this does is this brings into
fruition the idea of the Goblin formula
now the Goblin formula in and of itself
is really one of multiple instances when
Marvel kind of hit home with the idea
that everybody was trying to duplicate
the Super Soldier Serum of Steve Rogers
and in fact we'll cover this we'll talk
about this once we get into Ironman
extremists because futurepharm was
trying to copy the Super Soldier Serum
and come up with extremis instead but
the fact remains here that the Goblin
formula was designed to basically
enhance the various attributes of the
person who uses it the problem is that
it also breaks their sanity so they
literally lose their minds or at least
Norman Osborn
up losing his money now for the most
part different people have been affected
with it different ways you know for
example there was a girl by the name of
Lily Hollister who was actually dating
Norman Osborn for a little while and
stumbled across the Goblin formula the
difference is that when she ingested it
or when it basically bonded to her skin
that she can switch out of being a
goblin at will you know she's not bound
to losing her sanity she doesn't lose
her mind she can just kind of switch
back and forth how she wants to so
different people have been affected
different ways now if enough time passes
they'll just be gone in their entirety I
mean who they were before will vanish
and they'll just be left as a goblin but
for the moment for her character thinks
function a little bit differently now
from here we basically switched back to
the mindscape of Peter Parker now again
this is something that we've talked
about you know time and time again just
because of the fact that within the
realm of superior spider-man Doctor
Octopus had realized that the mind of
Peter Parker was still there because of
the fact that Peter Parker's
consciousness was tied directly to his
memories and so we're Doc Ock had
basically purged the memories of Peter
Parker ideally it approached Peter
Parker in his entirety the issue with
this is that when Doc Ock had basically
recalled on memories of Peter in order
to help him navigate Peters life that is
to say the memories of Peters romance
with Mary Jane Watson or when Aunt May
asked something that Doctor Octopus
didn't know the answer to and he
researched the memories of Peter Parker
in order to give her an answer what it
did is that basically made these
memories a core part of Doctor Octopus
and so Peter Parker's consciousness
remained alive there's only about 30
memories that are there but so long as
any facet of Peters memories are alive
his life forces essence are tied to
those and so because of the fact that
Octopus referenced those memories at
Peter Parker's essentially alive through
him the issue is that Doc Ock could
still purge Peter in his entirety and so
what happened is Peter basically began
jumping through doctor octopus's own
memories and what this was is it was Dan
Slott essentially giving us a scenario
where each guy learns about the other
Doctor Octopus learns about the life of
Peter Parker by being Peter Parker Peter
Parker learns about the life of Doctor
Octopus by jumping into his own memories
and what he sees is a mother who is
extremely aggressive in terms of showing
affection which is to say she keeps him
smothered someone and so forth he has a
father who's extremely abusive he's
picked on by kids at school because he's
socially awkward you know all this time
time and time again Doc Ock has been met
with
nothing but absolute oppression and just
being given a hard time by everybody and
so that guy grew up with a really bad
life and what this did is it allowed
Peter Parker to understand why Doc Ock
is a bad guy to understand where he's
coming from and why he's done the things
that he's done it's just been in pursuit
of some measure of acceptability or at
the very least trying to control his own
life and so with Norman Osborn making
his move across the city of New York the
response of Mayor Jay jonah Jameson is
to basically reactivate the the
spider-slayer protocol that was created
by Alastair Smith but in turn modified
this protocol so that the various
members of the you know anti spider
force as it was formed by Jameson would
be retrofitted with these new suits and
be allowed to carry out their goal of
basically clearing out New York of the
goblins themselves and essentially
restoring order now the reason why I say
this is basically the formation of
alchemax is because of the fact that
remember Liz Allen had basically taken
out Allen chemical you know al Kim and
then merged it with Oscorp for the
purpose of creating alchemax now of
course we know about the time displace
spider-man 2099 that was covered in the
last video oh really the video before
the last video but what this is doing is
basically saying this is how alchemax
comes into existence this is how
alchemax forms it's basically a merger
between Oscorp and Allen Chemical now in
terms of what role Norman Osborn has
eNOS will actually find out as we get
further into this story but the fact
remains here that with regards to to
Peter Parker himself with regards to
superior spider-man acting as Peter
Parker what this does is it really just
kind of begins to show us this struggle
that he saw in relation or at least
Peter saw in relation to Doc Ock in the
sense that when Doc Ock first became
Doctor Octopus when he underwent the
experiment that basically bonded the
tentacles to his body he in turn saw
himself as somebody who could finally
get some respect some guy who could
finally be treated you know as the
genius that he knew he was now of course
this is going to lead into the crushing
experience of facing off against Peter
Parker and that's when things are really
gonna kind of be kind of go awry but
it's also going to be the reason why doc
Octopus hated Peter Parker so much
because he was essentially the one guy
that just showed up and stood in his way
and he was a representation of a lot of
the other issues that he had but again
we'll cross that bridge when we get to
it the fact remains here that with
regards to really Carly Cooper you know
as one of the goblins invading Parker
Industries and going after so Johny
Joffrey and you know
Peter spider-man himself what we end up
finding out is that where Carly Cooper
was previously taken and turned into a
goblin she's not completely transformed
yet instead there's still some measure
of her there so while her physical
body's changed her mind is somewhat
intact but this is what we were talking
about when we were saying that
eventually a time will come when who a
person was will vanish in their entirety
and that's exactly what takes place here
with her as a person she still has her
mind intact and she tells you no
superior spider-man you have to make a
cure for this otherwise I will be gone
and Norman Osborn Green Goblin will
spread this formula across the city of
New York and everybody will be gone and
so again you know it creates kind of
this this this ticking time clock so to
speak now with regards to this formula
while he is working on it while superior
spider-man is putting it together
ultimately he has to bail out and the
reason why is because of the fact that
Green Goblin has essentially after
learning that superior spider-man is
Doctor Octopus waged a one-man war
against him and so this is really gonna
kind of serve as a distraction and the
reason why is because of the fact that
we're basically gonna have two conflicts
going on in the story at the same time
we're gonna have Green Goblin versus
superior spider-man and then we're gonna
have everybody else the Avengers and so
on going against the forces of the Green
Goblin so it's kind of like a a
two-stage conflict now this is Green
Goblin playing two different games and
the reason why is because of the fact
that while he is crazy while he is out
of his mind it's going to basically make
it difficult for superior spider-man to
actually create a cure for the Goblin
formula it's gonna make it difficult for
him to save the ones that he cares about
because he's torn either it's the city
of New York or is the individuals in his
life and if he has to make a choice
between which one which person will he
choose now of course in this instance
you know we also have a couple people
who were more or less lost you know
people who basically end up dying in the
conflict but the interesting thing about
this is that again superior spider-man
had established himself as a guy who
wasn't really concerned about casualties
unless they were wildly significant
unless they were employment then it was
just collateral damage that's the price
you pay when it comes to ward some folks
live in some folks die and that's just
the way it goes
now that was basically Dan Slott
differentiating him from Peter Parker
and in fact we'll find out just how
different these two are and what the
major failing is of superior spider-man
at this point but from here we again
have these spider-slayers as are
controlled by by Jameson and the police
and so on engaging superior spider-man
with the
intention of taking him out now the
reason why is because of the fact that
they look at superior spider-man and
they believe that he's in league with
the Green Goblin and the reason why is
because what they do is they look at his
track record keep in mind he's defeated
every major criminal in the city of New
York the only person left is the Green
Goblin - the person on the outside
looking in it would almost look like
superior spider-man was clearing out the
competition to make way for the Green
Goblin he was basically working on
behalf of Goblin to make the city easier
to conquer that's the initial indication
that's been received by Jameson and the
and the police and so on and so forth
and so we're Miguel O'Hara does jump in
and Miguel O'Hara tries to basically
help you know and again really kind of
allows superior spider-man to stay
captured for the purpose of gaining
answers ultimately these robots are
hijacked by Norman Osborn and so again
what this shows us is that whether we
knew it or not Osborn is tied into
alchemax he is involved in the creation
of these robots and does have a back
door and how to access them and so again
switching back to the mindscape of of a
Peter Parker this entire scenario is
really really intriguing because when it
shows as Peter directly what it gives us
are all these different conflicts with
Doctor Octopus and of course what we end
up finding out is that in the mind of
Doc Ock every time he was defeated by
Peter Parker it was yet another instance
of his father saying you're never gonna
be anything
it was another academic professor saying
you're dumb it's another instance of
kids who are basically saying get out of
here you're not one of us you're weird
it was all the different defeats that
Doc Ock had faced over the course of his
life manifested in the form of a
singular guy named spider-man and so
because of that the hatred that he had
for spider-man just stretched the
absolute limits because it was like
spider-man represented every instance in
which Doc Ock had met some kind of a
road block over the course of his life
and so with that in mind we essentially
have Peter Parker trying to find a way
back to his own body at the same time
that all this is happening again one of
the things that Dan Slott does I really
enjoyed is basically bringing in the
Avengers because on this surface with a
story like this where the whole of New
York is being attacked a lot of riders
would not include ancillary teams I mean
Bendis has done that on a multitude of
occasions they don't show the Avengers
it'll show anybody like that or any
other superheroes it's just this one guy
and we're somehow expected to believe
that the entire city of New York is
being attacked and this one hero
the only one who knows about it were the
only one who cares enough to do anything
about and so the cool thing about this
is like Captain America Iron Man Thor
Black Widow Wolverine Spider Woman the
New Avengers they're all responding
they're all you know doing what they can
to help keep New York safe now the way
they're depicted is within the Charter
of the Avengers themselves The Avengers
are a peacekeeping force no fight if
they have to but with the city of New
York right now the one behind all this
is the Green Goblin and so their job is
to take down whatever enemies are there
specifically the forces of the Green
Goblin and these different needs have
been spider-slayer robots would have
been co-opted and at the same time try
to save as many people as they can so
again it's not wildly important it's
just kind of cool to see this a little
bit of a story brought in this little
bit of the events included in this
conflict but the fact remains here that
with Peter Parker navigating this
mindscape and basically jeongmi back
through them memories of Doctor Octopus
and really kind of retro actively
retracing his steps what he basically
does is he accesses the mind of Doctor
Octopus accesses the mind of his younger
self and in turn gives birth to all
these memories again and so basically
he's able to tap into everything that
makes him who he was now the reason why
this matters is because of the fact that
many that Menace of course one of the
henchmen of the Green Goblin and several
others have created these traps around
the city of New York one of them is a
young girl named Amy chin now of course
Amy chin is one of the kids that the
superior spider-man had helped along the
way recovering from an illness but the
idea is that she's basically being
strapped in a subway station and she's
gonna be hit by subway train now this is
where the huge difference between Peter
Parker and superior spider-man comes
into play superior spider-man is
analyzing the scenario remember he's
trying to trace and trying to locate an
Tamar Coney and save her life that's its
girlfriend that's the woman that he's
romantically interested in along the way
there's this girl named Amy chin he
cannot do both he cannot save annamaria
Marconi and Amy chin or at least it
doesn't seem to be the case and so where
he's paralyzed with indecision Peter
Parker manifests suddenly and says you
have to jump you have to go and this is
when we basically get the return of
Peter Parker and the reason why is
because Peter says look you know your
brain your intelligence is a gift in a
lot of different ways the things that
you do you know the things that you've
been able to pull off or at least how
you look at things of course again Peter
doesn't know a lot of what's been going
on but he says you know the things that
you
down here are good in terms of how you
function the problem is when you have no
time to think you act when you have time
to think then you take that time but you
can't be pause you can't be paralyzed by
indecision because you're trying to make
the right choice and so in the end you
know Doctor Octopus basically realizes
that Peter had been navigating his mind
and so the indication seems to be here
that he let him that he let him
basically access his own memories but
the fact remains the Doctor Octopus and
Peter essentially reconciled
you know Doctor Octopus says look the
biggest issue that I had is that sure
you know I was arrogant but it was
because of the fact that I was trying to
overcompensate is because of the fact
that I knew I was not as smart as you
are but I wanted to pretend that I was
and so Peter Parker is really kind of
speechless throughout this whole thing
is because it's Doctor Octopus spilling
his guts out to Peter basically saying
you are a better
spider-man than I will ever be you know
because when it comes to to
self-sacrifice you do it without a
second thought but I can't bring myself
to do that and so again it's really kind
of this cool thing because it's like
this journey really and in some ways a
journey of Peter Parker in the sense
that it's almost like you know you don't
know what you have until it's gone and
so it's like Dan Slott basically saying
okay let's take Peter Parker as we know
him out of the equation with spider-man
let's put somebody else in his stead and
then let's see how these stories unfold
once we get to the end let's compare the
two and see how they stack up against
one another and so ultimately what Doc
Ock basically does is travel back to
Parker industries of course Peter Parker
being totally surprised by the fact that
there is a Parker Industries but they
travel back to the building and Peter
Parker regains his memories he goes back
to his normal self and what we get is
this amazing thing because we have Peter
Parker back to himself back in his own
body he gets rid of the superior
spider-man sued he puts on his amazing
spider-man suit and he says my turn and
it's so cool it's one of the coolest
things I was reading this and I was like
oh my god amazing spider-man it's back
and it's one of the coolest things to
happen because as soon as Peter Parker
regains control of his own body remember
he has no idea what's been going on with
like Parker Industries what's been going
on with horizon labs he has no idea
what's been happening there instead all
he knows is that he's just back now so I
mean you know Carly Cooper being turned
into a goblin he didn't know about that
you know the launch of Parker industry
so Johnny joffrey and Anna Maria Marconi
working for the company he didn't know
about that so as soon as he shows up he
just starts getting screamed
by people there was like why have you
been gone all this time you know and and
carrying on because of the fact that you
know again superior spider-man had
basically taken off he had made Parker
Industries and then banished from the
company for like a month he had
abandoned Miguel O'Hara to face off
against all these different Spider
Slayer robots and then when he shows
back up again the Oh Miguel O'Hara kind
of freaks out on him now again this is
really kind of cool because the two of
them of course end up teaming up and
Peter Parker jumps back in the conflict
alongside the rest of the Avengers and
really kind of making up for the things
that superior spider-man did where
superior spider-man with the Avengers
Peter Parker rejoins different things
like that now of course when we end up
getting into the direct conflict between
the Green Goblin along the way Peter
Parker had basically been doing things
like injecting minute menace with a cure
for the Goblin formula which basically
turns her back in an all you know turns
her back to normal again they've been
doing this almost every step of the way
ah but with the return with the conflict
between Peter and Norman Osborn
basically on the rooftop alongside Anna
Maria Marconi Green Goblin learns that
Peter Parker's back because of the fact
that Green Goblin makes a joke about how
green Goblin's gonna destroy yes yeah
Green Goblin makes a joke about how he's
gonna destroy everything that spider-man
loves and spider-man will say it says
you know well the only thing that I'm
left with is the dignity of knowing that
I never carried a man-purse
so despite the fact with respite a man
giving Green Goblin [ __ ] about his
satchel that's how he knows that Peter
Parker's back it's amazing I absolutely
love this part of the story it's one of
the coolest things but again it's really
kind of refreshing to see Peter Parker
back because with his character what it
does is it creates urgency and it
creates struggle and it creates strife
because Peter Parker saves everyone
right like no one dies whenever it is at
Peter Parker's around if at all possible
with superior spider-man the
storytelling had to be a little bit
different because he'll kill bad guys
we've seen that it was just like we're
gonna kill him and then we're gonna be
done with it and they won't come back
that's that but when Peter Parker is in
a scenario where he has to save
annamaria Marconi and he has to defeat
the Green Goblin while going without
letting Green Goblin die basically
saving his life then it makes things
difficult and it makes things hard now
in terms of the whole idea with alchemax
we end up having this situation where we
will basically learn that Norman Osborn
had had his face changed that what he
did is he took on the name of a guy
named Mason banks and he began operating
as a
though investor on behalf of Osborne's
born industries and so because of that I
guess on an Oscorp rather and so because
of that what he did is he turn around
and invested alongside and Liz Allen
which in turn allowed for the merger of
Oscorp and Al Corp to create alchemax
and so again this is really kind of a
funny scenario because what is up
happening here is Peter Parker basically
turns the robots these little you know
these little goblin BOTS against Mason
banks himself which really just kind of
leaves him incapacitated slightly or
enough that he's lost his goblin you
know his goblin abilities because of the
injection that Peter Parker gave him
basically curing him of the Goblin
formula but in saving annamaria Marconi
he also saves you know Norman Osborn
with a different face at the same time
and so again what this does is kind of
wrap things up because Norman Osborn
essentially escapes he basically just
kind of gets away and that's really that
kind of takes off into the tunnels and
Dan Slott leaves it open-ended you know
for Norman Osborn to come back later on
down the line but we all well we also
end up having here is this notion that
Anna Maria Marconi still doesn't know
everything that's going on she doesn't
know that Doctor Octopus was in the body
of Peter Parker as far as she is aware
it's Peter Parker who's in love with her
and so what Dan Slott does is he kind of
leaves this open and says there will be
fallout there will be consequences there
will be ramifications in the Amazing
Spiderman line of stories when things go
back to normal because what we're
basically gonna have is Peter Parker
having to sit down and explain to the
various members of the the people in his
life who he is and what exactly it was
that was going on so again it's really
kind of a cool bit of storytelling it's
really a pretty interesting tidbit of
events that were that we're taking place
but if you guys are new here to come
let's explain make sure you guys hit the
sub button to become part of the raw
pork if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and yeah I will
catch you guys later peace
[Music]